THIRTY SECOND WARNING.
ALRIGHT WE'RE GOING.
.
BE
OKAY WE'LL GET GOING WITH
TODAY'S BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING ON
EDUCATION FINANCE.
THIS IS A ON ONE ISSUE TODAY
RELATES TO OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
MANY COLLEGES THIS IS IT A JOINT
HEARING.
WE HAVE INVITED THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO
PARTICIPATE.
WELL CHAIRMAN MEDINA AND A FEW
OTHERS. ARE ON THEIR WAY. BUT WE
WERE ALL OUT WE WILL BEGIN.
WE'LL HAVE THE ART DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THAT THE LA OPEN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES GIVE AN OVERVIEW. OF
THE NEW FUNDING FORMULA THAT
PROPOSAL.
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
WERE INTRIGUED ABOUT LAST YEAR
PASSED THE LA OUT TO HELP US.
FRAME THE ISSUE AND.
TALK ABOUT OPPORTUNITIES
TO MAKE SURE WE INVEST IN OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
FOCUSING ON. HOW THE STUDENTS
WHO COULD UTILIZE THE MOST HELP
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE DID WITH LCF
HALF?
AND.
.
RIGHT ABOUT THE SAME TIME THAT
ELLIOT CAME OUT THE REPORT THE
GOVERNOR CAME OUT WITH A
PROPOSAL IN THE JANUARY TEN
BUDGET SO. WE CAN LOOK AT THAT
IDEA TODAY. EVALUATES IT AND.
.
PUT PUT INTO CONSIDERATION FOR
THE. FINAL BUDGET SO WITH THAT
BALLOTS BEGIN BLAST FIRST THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO GIVE US
AN OVERVIEW.
IT THINK HUMOR ITS VOTE HE SAU
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AS A BEFORE ID TOME AND PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW OF THE PROPOSAL FOR
STUDENT FOCUSED FUNDING FORMULA
I WANT TO BEGIN BY. I'M
PROVIDING SOME BRIEF BACKGROUND
ON THE EXISTING MODEL AND
HIGHLIGHT THE PROBLEMS AND AND
CONCERNS WITH THE EXISTING I'M
FUNNY MODEL. SO COMMITTEE
COLLEGES CURRENTLY RECEIVE ABOUT
THREE QUARTERS OF DEFINING
THROUGH GENERAL PURPOSE PORTION
MEN'S IT'S ABOUT SEVEN.
AT BILLION FOR PORTION MEN'S
PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. A PORTION OF FUNDING IS
DISTRIBUTED TO DISTRICT.
TO DISTRICTS BASED PRIMARILY ON
A ROMANCE OF FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT STUDENTS AB T. S..
I WOULD NOTE THAT F. T. AS HIS
GENERATED GENERALLY CALCULATED
ON ENROLLMENT OF STUDENTS AT A
SPECIFIC POINT IN TIME WHICH
TYPICALLY OCCURS AT AT SAYS
SENSES STATE EARLY AM IN THE
TERM.
WE KNOW THAT FUNDING MODELS
OFTEN THE MODELS CREATE
INCENTIVES
AND A PRIMARY CONCERN WITH THE
EXISTING A ROMAN BASE FUNNY
MODEL IS THAT IT ENCOURAGES
DISTRICTS TO PRIORITIZE.
ENROLLMENT AND ENROLLMENT
GROWTH.
WITHOUT REGARD FOR STUDENT
SUCCESS SUCH AS TIMELY
COMPLETION AND BETTER SERVING
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS.
THE CURRENT MODEL ACTUALLY
DISCOURAGES DISTRICTS FROM
INNOVATIVE PRACTICES THAT REDUCE
I'M ACCESS UNITS AN INCREASE
TIMELY COMPLETION GIVEN THAT
THAT CAN RESULT IN A REDUCTION
OF AB T. AS. AND AS A RESULT OF
REDUCTION OF REVENUE FOR THE
COLLEGE.
THE EXISTING ENROLLMENT BASED
MONEY MODEL IS ALSO CREATING
SIGNIFICANT LONG TERM PLANNING
HARDSHIPS FOR DISTRICTS BECAUSE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ROMANCE IS
COUNTER CYCLICAL TO THAT KIND OF
ME. SO WE KNOW THAT WHEN
ECONOMIC TIMES ARE GOOD
COMMITTEE COLLEGE ENROLLMENT
REMAINS FLATTER DECLINE SWITCHES
WHAT IS CURRENTLY HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW. AND WHEN ECONOMIC
TIMES ARE BAD.
A ROMAN DEMAND INCREASES AT THE
SAME TIME FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE GENERALLY INCREASES WHEN
ECONOMIC TIMES ARE GOOD AND
DECLINES WHEN ECONOMIC TIMES OUR
BATTLE IS REALLY. A DISCONNECT
THERE.
SO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES IN NEW SUIT AND FOCUS
FUNDING FORMULA FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICABLE EDGES
THAT RECOGNIZES FACTORS BEYOND
THE NUMBER OF FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT STUDENTS ENROLLED.
THE PRIMARY GOAL IS TO ALIGN THE
FUNNY MODEL WITH THE GOALS OF
THE VISION FOR SUCCESS AND THE
SERVE STUDENTS AND TO ELIMINATE
EQUITY CAPS.
MOVING AWAY FROM ENROLLMENT BASE
FUNNY MODEL IS ALSO EXPECTED TO
CREATE GREATER FISCAL STABILITY
FOR DISTRICTS.
THE PROPOSAL IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AT CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR COLLEGES TO GROW FISCALLY BY
IMPROVING ON STUDENT SUCCESS
METRICS AND ENSURING ACCESS FOR
LOW INCOME STUDENTS.
BY MOVING AWAY FROM ENROLLMENT
GROWTH MODEL AND SAID FOCUSING
ON TIMELY COMPLETION OF
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS REDUCING
EXCESS UNITS AND FURTHERING
STUDENT SUCCESS EFFORTS. IT ALSO
EXPANDS ACCESS BY CREATING ROOM
FOR ADDITIONAL ENROLLMENT WHICH
IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT DURING
A RECESSION.
TO ACCOMPLISH THESE GOALS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES A
FUNDING FORMULA FOR PORTION
MEN'S WITH THREE COMPONENTS.
FIRST EACH DISTRICT WOULD
RECEIVE A BASE GRANT THAT IS
BASED ON A ROMANTIC AT SOMEONE
TO THE EXISTING.
MODEL.
SLIPPED FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
STUDENT RATE AS THAT WOULD BE A
PROP UP PLATE ACROSS THE
DISTRICTS.
EACH A STRIP WILL ALSO RECEIVE A
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF LOW INCOME STUDENTS
THAT THE DISTRICT ENROLLS
SPECIFICALLY THIS INCLUDES
ENROLLMENT OF STUDENTS RECEIVE A
CALIFORNIA CALLED A CALIFORNIA
ON COLLEGE PROMISE GRANT. THE
WAIVER AND ENROLLMENT OF
STUDENTS RECEIVE A PELL GRANT.
FINALLY EACH DISTRICT RECEIVED A
STUDENT SUCCESS INCENTIVE GRANT
BASED ON THE NUMBER OF DEGREES
AND CERTIFICATES GRANTED AND THE
NUMBER STUDENTS TO COMPLETE A
DEGREE OR CERTIFICATE OR
TRANSFER IN THREE YEARS OR LESS.
THE GRANT ALSO INCLUDES
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR EACH
ASSOCIATE DEGREE.
FOR TRANSFER EDT GRANTED AS A
WAY TO FURTHER AND SEND DATA
SEAMLESS TRANSFER AND
EXPERIENCE.
THE PROPOSAL ASSUMES THAT
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY PERCENT OF
GENERAL PURPOSE APPORTIONMENT
WOULD BE DISTRIBUTED INITIALLY
AS A BASE GROUND AT TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT DISTRIBUTED AS A
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT. AND TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT DISTRIBUTED AS THE.
AS PART OF THE STUDENT SUCCESS
INCENTIVE GRANTS.
UNDER THE PROPOSAL DISTRICTS
WOULD ALSO BE REQUIRED TO ALIGN
I'D THE GOALS IN THEIR EDUCATION
MASTER PLANS WHAT THE GOALS
OUTLINED IN THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS INCLUDING ACTIONS FOR
MEASURING PROGRESS TOWARDS A
SCHOOLS. AND DISTRICTS WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO ALIGN THEIR BUDGETS
WITHOUT REVISED AT MASTER PLAN
BY THE DATE DETERMINED BY THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
TO SUPPORT DISTRICTS TRANSITION
TO THIS NEW STUDENT CENTER
FUNDING FORMULA THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND. TO
ENSURE THAT NO DISTRICT RECEIVES
LESS RELATIVE TO THE CURRENT
APPORTIONMENT A FUNDING FORMULA
AND SO THERE ARE TWO COMPONENTS
TO THIS HOLD HARMLESS. AFTER THE
FIRST YEAR OF IMPLEMENTATION
WHICH WOULD BE AN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN EACH DISTRICT WOULD
RECEIVE NO LESS THAN THE TOTAL
APPORTIONMENT FUNDING THAT THE
DISTRICT RECEIVED AND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN. EACH YEAR THERE AFTER
THE HOLD HARMLESS WILL BE
CALCULATED BY MULTIPLYING THE
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN PURSUED AT
RATES TIMES THE ABBOTT DISTRICTS
ENROLLMENT.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES A HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE
POINT TWO MILLION PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR
TWO POINT FIVE ONE COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENTS. THESE FUNDS
WOULD BE BUILT INTO THE BASE
RATES OF THE PROPOSED A FUNDING
FORMULA. AND PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
BASE RESOURCES FOR DISTRICTS.
AND FINALLY A NOTE ON
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET CALLS ON THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO CONSULT
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP A
PROPOSAL FOR CONSIDERATION.
WITHIN THE MAY REVISIONS THAT
WOULD CONSOLIDATE CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS AND AND THE GOAL HERE
IS REALLY TO CREATE A MORE
FLEXIBILITY FLEXIBILITY WE OFTEN
HEAR. THAT THERE'S A NEED AYE
FOR MORE FLEXIBILITY SO COLLEGES
ARE ABLE TO BEST A DEPLOY THE
RESOURCES I TO MEET THEIR.
LOCAL NEEDS THE MOST
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY WAY
POSSIBLE SO AND THAT THAT'S
ANOTHER COMPONENT OF OF THE
BROADER AND FRAMEWORK. AND I
THINK YOU ARE HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU LA.
GOOD AFTERNOON NETWORK BROUGHT
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. AND I THINK THIS IS AN
ISSUE IT DESCRIPTIVE AT THAT
ADMINISTER THAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S HAD A SIGNIFICANT
TRISTEN NAME A NUMBER OF ANGLES.
I'M FIRST OF THE CHAIRMAN JIM
THERE IS INTERESTING AND NOT
REFORMING THE FUNDING FORMULA
AND THE LEGISLATURE AFTER OFFICE
TO.
LOOK AT THE FUNDING AND
SERVICES FOR FIRST GENERATION
AND LOW INCOME. I'M.
SERVICES THAT THEY ARE IN DIRE
COMMITTEE BECAUSE BUT ALSO TO
YOU SEE SEAT AT THE IF YOU
SYSTEM. AND OUR OFFICE PUBLISHED
A REPORT IN LATE DECEMBER THAT.
LAID OUT FOR THE COMMITTEE
COLLEGES TO OPTIONS FOR REFORM
THAT INCLUDE A WE DID STERN
FORMULA AURA. AND CONSOLIDATED
CONSOLIDATING CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS INTO A BLOCK GRANT.
AND THERE ALSO HAVE BEEN
NUMEROUS.
OUR EFFORTS NOT ON THE FUNDING
SITE BUT IN THE INTEREST OF
IMPROVING STUDENT OUTCOMES OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS. AND I'M
WE DO OUR HAND OUT THOSE PASSED
A TWO AND ON PAGE TWO OF THAT
HAND OUT WE WALKED THROUGH MANY
OF THE.
RECENT STUDENTS THAT SUPPORT
EFFORTS
I'M BEGINNING WITH THAT THE
STUDENT SUCCESS TASK FORCE AND
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE TRIPLETS
BEFORE THEM THE STUDENTS ACROSS
IN SPORT PROGRAM.
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN
FUNDING FOR BASIC SKILLS TO
IMPROVE REMEDIATION EFFORTS.
I'M THE LEGISLATURE ALSO I'M A
TOOK ACTION TO.
CREATE THE ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR
TRANSFER AREN'T TO STREAMLINE
THE PROCESS OF TRANSFERRED FROM
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO THE
CSU SYSTEM SO. A LOT OF INTEREST
IN THIS AREA IN A NUMBER OF
WAYS.
I'M.
I WOULD AND INCOMES OR HAND ARE
BUT IF YOU MOVE TO PAGE FIVE I
THINK THE MISTRESS TO WALK
THROUGH THAT. THE COMPONENTS OF
THE PROPOSAL.
INSUFFICIENT DETAIL I THINK ARE
JUST.
I'M IN TERMS OF OUR OVERALL
PERSPECTIVE I DO THINK WE WE
THINK IT.
PARA WE DO RECOMMEND MOVING TO
AN APPROACH THAT HAS A CHANGE OF
THE FUNDING FOR ME TO INCLUDE A
PERFORMANCE BASED COMPONENT. I'M
SO MUCH OF ADMINISTRATION.
I THINK.
WE SHARE MANY OF THE SAME
CONCERNS THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS WITH REGARDS TO THE COURT
ENROLLMENT BASED. APPROACH
WHICH.
IN MANY WAYS INHIBIT SOME
INNOVATION BY.
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT MANY
OF THE REFORMS THAT WE WANT TO
BLACKS YOU. COULD RESULT IN
FEWER.
UNITS BEING TAKEN BY STUDENTS
SO I'M WE WE WE SERVE THOSE
CONCERNS AND WE THINK ALSO THAT
THE. ARAB PROVIDING THAT THIS
PROBLEM AT THE FUNDING COMPONENT
REALLY OUTLINES ARE A LOT OF THE
THE FUNDING FROM THAT SOLVE TO
MANY OF THE GOALS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS FOR THE SYSTEM
IN TERMS OF. IMPROVING OUTOMES.
AND.
IT AN IMPROVING THOSE IN A MORE
TIMELY MANNER.
WE DID LOOK AT WHAT THE RESEARCH
SHOWS BECAUSE THERE ARE MORE
THAN THIRTY STATES ARM WHO DO
HAVE SOME PERFORMANCE BASED
FUNDING IN THE HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEMS.
NUMBER THAT RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
IN GENERAL I'M. OF THERE'S A
CORRELATION BETWEEN CHANGING
YOUR FUNDING FORMULA TO A
PERFRMANCE BASED ARE FUNDING
APPROACH AND SING INSTITUTIONAL
CHANGES MANY OF WHICH I THINK WE
WOULD CONSIDER. THE KINDS OF
CHANGES THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
BEEN WANTING TO SEE OF THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS THINGS LIKE. I'M
CHANGING ARE THE YOUR APPROACH
TO TO REMEDIATION TO IMPROVE
OUTCOMES FOR BASIC SKILLS
PROGRAMS.
I'M PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
ADVISING IN SUPPORT STUDENTS SO
THAT ARE MEANT TO HELP GET THEM
THROUGH THE SYSTEM M. DROP OPENS
PROGRAMS THINGS LIKE THAT.
NUMBER DESPITE THOSE CHANGES IN
BEHAVIOR THAT THE RESEARCH
DOESN'T SHOW A SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT IN. INSTANT OUTCOMES
WOULD THINK WE WE MEANT TO
ADJUST THE STATE THIS IN AND OF
ITSELF IS NOT IS NOT GONNA BE
SUFFICIENT TO MAKE SUBSTANTIAL
CHANGES BUT WE THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT. THAT IS WORTH
PURSUING BECAUSE IT DOES HELP
ONLINE THE GOAL THAT WE HAVE FOR
THE SYSTEM WITH WITH VOTE THE
FUNDING APPROACH.
I'M.
THERE ARE THERE A COUPLE OF KEY
THINGS IN UP AT SIX O'CLOCK OR
SOME OF THE KEY ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE WITH THE SPECIFIC
COMPONENTS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL.
FIRST IN TERMS OF THE THOSE
OUTCOMES BASED.
COMPONENT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT THE. THE THE INCENTIVES
THAT THEY COULD CREATE UNTIL THE
FIRST IS RELATED TO.
TO LOW INCOME STUDENTS AND
OTHER STUDENTS WHO ARE.
WHO COME INTO THE SYSTEM? WE
LEFT PREPARED IF LIKELY TO IT TO
COME OUT OF THE SYSTEM. I'M THE
FORMULA CREATES AN INCENTIVE TO
ENROLL MORE OF THE STUDENTS
BECAUSE THERE'S A SPECIFIC
COMPONENT FOR. A GOING CONCERN
COUNTS BUT THERE ISN'T A
SPECIFIC INCENTIVE TO HELP
STUDENTS TO COMPLETE THEIR
DEGREE ERA OR.
CERTIFICATE OR TO TRANSFER IN A
TIMELY MANNER THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE SEEN IN OTHER IN
OTHER STATES WHEN THEY'VE
ADOPTED THESE.
THESE KINDS OF FORMULAS ARM
THAT OFTENTIMES ARE COLLEGES
MIGHT CHOOSE TO FOR EXAMPLE
FOCUS ON STUDENTS ONE OF THE
MOST PREPARED BECAUSE THEY MIGHT
FIND IT TO BE MORE COST
EFFECTIVE WAY OF IMPROVING THEIR
OUTCOME.
SO WE THINK ONE WAY DEBT TO
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE IS TO PROVIDE
DIFFERENCE ALL A FUNDING SO THAT
YOU PROVIDE HIGHER OUTCOMES
BASED FUNDING.
FOR.
FOR THE OUTCOMES OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS.
BUT SIMILARLY WE WEREN'T WE SAW
THE RESEARCH OF CONCERNS ON ON
THE.
AND SOME COLLEGE OF MOVING TO
MORE SHORT TERM.
CERTIFICATE PROGRAMS AS BECAUSE
THOSE ARE CHEAPER YOU ACTED TO
PRODUCE OUTCOMES TO IMPROVE
INCREASE YOUR FUNDING.
IT'S I THINK AGAIN WE THINK OF
ONE ONE THING FOR YOU TO
CONSIDER IS ARE MAKING A
INCREASE IN THE AMOUNT OF
OCCAM'S YOU PROVIDE FOR SOME OF
THOSE. HIGH COST PROGRAMS FOR
EXAMPLE SOME OF CITY PROGRAMS
THAT MAY BE A MORE EXPENSIVE FOR
COLLEGES. TO OPERATE BUT BUT WE
THINK ARE ARE ARE PROVIDED A
SIGNIFICANT STATEWIDE VALUE.
THE THE THE OTHER ISSUE THAT
COMES UP THAT WE THINK ERA CAN
BE A THOUGHT BY MONITORING ERA
IS IS THIS CONCERN THAT THERE
MIGHT BE INFLATION UPGRADES OF
COLLEGES.
KNOW THAT THEY WILL BE REWARDED
BY GETTING STUDENTS UP THE DOOR
IS SOMETHING THAT WE'VE WE'VE
HEARD IN OTHER STATES AS A
CONCERN THERE IS ENOUGH EARLY
STRONG EVIDENCE THAT IT'S
HAPPENING BUT WE DO THINK
SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN. ADDRESS
BY HAVING ADDITIONAL MONITORING.
AND THEN FINALLY ON THE ISSUE OF
OF THE CONSOLIDATING OUR ORDERED
DEALING WITH THEIR OTHER THE
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS WHICH
REPRESENT. ABOUT A QUARTER OF
COMMUNICATIVE NINETY FUNDING WE
DO THINK THAT IT'S BONTA
CONSIDER THOSE PROGRAMS IN
TANDEM WITH THE SUPPLEMENTAL
FUNDING THAT'S PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED FORMULA.
BOTH OF THOSE FORMULAS ARE BOTH
TRYING TO PROVIDED ADDITIONAL
FUNDING IN RECOGNITION THAT
THERE ARE SOME STUDENTS IN THE
SYSTEM THAT NEED ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT. AND WE THINK THERE'S A
BIT OF A DISCONNECT RIGHT NOW
WITH ONE FUNDING STREAM THAT'S A
VERY FLEXIBLE ARE VERY FEW
REQUIREMENTS AND IN THE
CATEGORICAL AS WITH A LOT OF
RESTRICTIONS. ARE A BUNCH OF
VERY DIFFERENT PROGRAMS FOR VERY
SPECIFIC PURPOSES.
SO IN TERMS OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS I'M WE DO
RECOMMEND YEAH I'M SHIFTING OUR
APPROACH. AND AND WE THINK I'M
THERE'S NO SORT OF. EXACTLY
HARDER FAST RULE FOR WHAT WE
THINK MAKES SENSE BUT WE DO
THINK THERE. THE GOVERNOR'S
APPROACH OF.
SHIFTING TO ONLY HALF OF THE
FORMULA BEING BASED ON
ENROLLMENT IS REASONABLE.
WE ALSO THINK THAT PROVIDING I'M
FUNDING BASED ON OUR PERFORMANCE
WE'VE YOU WANTED TO KEEP IT IS
SUBSTANTIAL SO THAT YOU HAVE
SUFFICIENT INCENTIVES FOR
COLLEGES WE THINK. BASED ON WHAT
WE'VE SEEN THE RESEARCH THAT
TWENTY PERCENT OR MORE.
IS IS IS SUFFICIENT TO ENSURE
THAT THE CASE.
I'M AS I MENTIONED WE DO
RECOMMEND THAT YOU THAT THAT THE
OUTCOMES BASED COMPONENTS
BETWEEN SO THAT YOU PROVIDING
MORE OUTCOME MORE FUNDING FOR
OUTCOMES FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS.
AND FOR A MORE EXPENSIVE HIGH
VALUE PROGRAMS.
I'M AND THEN IN TERMS OF THE
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS WE WOULD
RECOMMEND LOOKING AT THE
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS AND THE
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANTS TOGETHER.
COLLAPSING THEM INTO ONE LARGER.
POT THAT WOULD BE ABOUT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD SPECIFY THAT
THE STUDENTS THAT. THAT YEAR
INTENDING TO SERVE WITHOUT
AMOUNT AND THEN HAVE FEW STRINGS
BUT HAVE A SIGNIFICANT REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS IN TERMS OF HOW
THAT FUNDING. IS BEING SPENT AT
EACH COLLEGE
I'M.
AND FINALLY WE WE DO RECOMMEND
MONITORING A COUPLE ASPECTS TO
ENSURE THAT THE SYSTEM IS BEING
IMPLEMENTED AS INTENDED.
MONITORING A NEW PROGRAM OR AT
THE NEW PROGRAMS THAT ARE
CREATED TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
NOT SERVE ONLY FOCUS ON THE
SHORT TERM PROGRAMS. MONITOR
GREAT RELATED DATA TO IT TO
MONITOR TO SEE IF THERE IS ANY
KIND OF GRADE INFLATION. AND.
MONITORING THE TYPES OF.
DEGREES AND CERTIFICATES
AWARDED TO SEE IF WE ARE.
SEEING A DIFFERENCE IN THAT THE
KINDS OF PROGRAMS THAT ARE
BEING.
PRIORITIZE BY COLLEGES.
SO DON'T HAVE TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
THANK YOU MANY COLLEGES CHRISTOS
MANY OF US CHANCELLOR FOR THEIR
TELL PARTICULARLY COLLEGES. BUT.
I HAVE A HANDOUT THAT WE'VE
PASSED OUT TOO MANY OF THE
SLIDES COVER MUCH OF THE GROUND
THAT WAS COVERED BY THE OTHER
PRISONERS ALL MOVE QUICKLY
THROUGH THEM. BOB TO BEGIN I
JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR WE SUPPORT
THE FRAMEWORK PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE THINK THERE
ARE WAYS WE CAN PROVE THE
FORMULA ITSELF.
AND WE AGREE WITH MANY OF THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT I'LL TALK TO
YOU MORE OF OUR THOUGHTS AS WE
MOVE ALONG. I JUST TO BE CLEAR
AS WE.
TALK ABOUT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FINANCE ALL THE TALKING BOTH
ABOUT THE GENERAL PORTION
FORMULA AND ABOUT CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS.
SO PAGE TWO COVERS OUR CURRENT
PRACTICE AGAIN AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
EXPLAIN THIS WELL WE FUNDED
GENERAL PORSCHE MEANT BASED ON A
COMBINATION OF STATE FUNDS
PROPERTY TAXES AND ENROLLMENT
FEES DISTRICTS RECEIVE THOSE
FUNDS CURRENTLY LARGELY ON THE
BASIS OF FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
STUDENTS ENROLLED. WE'VE GOT
SOME FUNDING.
IN THERE ALSO BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF COLLEGES AND CENTERS
IN A DISTRICT AS WELL SOME OTHER
DISTRICT CHARACTERISTICS THE
MOST PROMINENT IS.
SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
RURAL DISTRICTS.
AND IN IN ADDITION TO THE
GENERAL APPORTIONMENT WE FUND A
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS ABOUT A
THIRD OF THE FUNDING IS FINANCE
MENTIONED IS FOR THOSE PURPOSES.
WE OFTEN TALK ABOUT STUDENT
SERVICES CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS
THINGS LIKE THE STUDENT SUCCESS
IN SUPPORT PROGRAM STUDENT
EQUITY PROGRAM. BASIC SKILLS BUT
WE ALSO HAVE CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS FOR ECONOMIC AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
THE MOST PROMINENT ONE IS THE
STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM YOU ALL
CREATED.
SEVERAL YEARS AGO A WE HAVE A
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
INSTRUCTIONAL KIKWIT MAKE
CATEGORICAL AND SO WE HAVE WE
HAVE CATEGORICAL IS FOR A NUMBER
OF PURPOSES.
ON PAGE THREE.
WE SHOW THE DATA THAT FINANCE
REFERENCED
SO WE HAVE ABOUT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE GENERAL
APPORTIONMENT WHEN YOU TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE STATE FUNDS THE
PROPERTY TAXES IN THE STUDENT
FEES. THE REMAINDER OF FUNDING.
ABOUT ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN IS
IN THE FORM OF CATEGORICAL
FUNDS.
PAGE FOUR IS THE PROBLEM
STATEMENT AGAIN WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THIS YOU KNOW I THINK.
THE VISION FOR SUCCESS
HIGHLIGHTS.
BUT THE CHALLENGES WE SEE IN
THE SYSTEM I THINK IT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE ARE.
YOU KNOW WE THINK WE HAVE IT
OUR BOARD HAS ACKNOWLEDGED.
THE CHALLENGES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS FACE MOST
STUDENTS DON'T.
ATTAINED A DEGREE OR
CERTIFICATE OR TRANSFER THOSE
THAT DO TAKE A LONG TIME TO DO
SO AND WE SEE GAPS BOTH ACROSS
STUDENT GROUPS ACROSS REGIONS.
AND THEN WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THE
PRINT PERVERSE INCENTIVES
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE ECONOMIC AND
DEMOGRAPHIC TRENDS THAT WE
TYPICALLY ASSOCIATE WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ENROLLMENT.
THINGS LIKE HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION ARMS.
CLASS SIZES AND ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS WHEN THOSE.
TRANSMIT ENROLLMENT GROWTH
DIFFICULT TO ACHIEVE.
SOME PAGE FIVE.
MMHM
THIS IS OUR ATTEMPT TO MAKE
EXPLICIT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
WITH THE FOREIGN LET ME THINK
ABOUT THREE DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT WE'RE DOING. BOB ONE OF
THEM IS ENCOURAGING PROGRESS
TOWARDS THE VISION FOR SUCCESS
IN THIS IS.
YOU KNOW I THINK THE THEORY OF
ACTION THAT DRIVES WHAT MOST
PEOPLE THINK OF AS PERFORMANCE
SPACE THROUGHOUT COME SPACE
FUNDING. THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
THROUGH A VARIETY OF MECHANISMS
ENCOURAGE BETTER INSTITUTIONAL
PERFORMANCE.
BUT I THINK THE SECOND PART IS
I THINK WHAT MAKES THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND AND THE
FRAMEWORK THAT WE THINK MAKE
SOUNDS A LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN
TRADITIONAL OUTCOME SPACE
FUNDING THAT. MORE LIKE THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA WE
THINK IT MAKES SENSE TO ALLOCATE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ARM. BASED
ON CHARACTERISTICS OF STUDENTS
THAT SUGGESTS THAT THEY FACE
ESPECIALLY HIGH BARRIERS TO
SUCCESS.
I MEAN WE THINK IT MAKES SENSE
TO ALLOCATE A SUBSTANTIAL
PORTION OF OF THE FUNDING BASED
ON THAT.
AND THEN AT PRINCIPLE THAT WE.
THINK IS IMPORTANT AND
CERTAINLY I THINK THE
INSTITUTIONS THINK IS IMPORTANT.
HAS THAT MOVING FORWARD FUNDING
FOR THOSE NEED TO BE STABLE AND
PREDICTABLE BUT ALSO.
PROVIDE THEM WITH FLEXIBILITY
TO TO MAKE THE KINDS OF CHANGES
NECESSARY TO SUCCEED IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT.
THE MEN THAT SECOND BULLET IS
INTENDED TO HIGHLIGHT I THINK
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
THINKING THROUGH AS WE MOVE
THROUGH THIS PROCESS. IS HOW DO
THE TYPES OF THE WAYS IN WHICH
WE DESIGNED A NEW FUNDING
FORMULA ALIGNED WITH THE OTHER
TYPES OF INITIATIVES THAT WE'VE.
THAT WE'VE UNDERTAKEN IN RECENT
YEARS YOU KNOW GUIDED PATHWAYS
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS
PREVIOUSLY IS THE WAY IN WHICH
WE SEEK TO. ALLY AND A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT STUDENT SUCCESS
INITIATIVES IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TOGETHER GUIDED
PATHWAYS SUGGESTS THAT WE SHOULD
UPON A STUDENT CENTURY
UNDERSTAND THEIR EDUCATIONAL
GOAL. PUT THEM ON A PATHWAY
THAT'S CONSISTENT WITH THAT GOAL
AND PROVIDE THEM WITH THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED TO GET BETTER
AND SO I THINK.
YOU KNOW UNDER GUIDED PATHWAYS
WE HAVE A SET OF KEY INDICATORS
THAT WE THINK ARE IMPORTANT A
MONITOR.
PIECE OR THINGS LIKE A
COMPLETION OF TRANSFER LEVEL
MATH AND ENGLISH IN THE FIRST
YEAR AS A WAY IN WHICH WE THINK.
WE ARE PUTTING STUDENTS ON A
BETTER PATH TO SUCCESS WERE
WORKING THROUGH THOSE TYPES OF
ISSUES.
AS WE THINK THROUGH THE FUNDING
FORMULA AND SO OBVIOUSLY THAT
INCLUDES BASIC SKILLS REFORM BUT
IT ALSO INCLUDES A LOT OF THE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING A STRONG
WORKFORCE PROGRAM TO RECOGNIZE
NOT ONLY TRANSFER OUTCOMES. BUT
ALSO ABOUT CAREER OUTCOMES.
SO THE NEXT SLIDE TALKS ABOUT.
.
THE DIFFERENT WAYS IN WHICH WE
HAVE ENGAGED IN THIS PROPOSAL
SENSE OF THE RELEASE OF THE
JANUARY BUDGET.
SO IN JANUARY.
WASH ALL ALL BEGIN BY SAYING
THAT WE HAVE A STANDING ADVISORY
WORK GROUP ON FISCAL AFFAIRS.
THIS IS A GROUP THAT LARGELY
CONSISTS OF CHIEF BUSINESS
OFFICIALS FROM A VARIETY OF
DISTRICTS THAT REPRESENT ADAM
SOME OF THE DIVERSITY IN OUR
SYSTEM. AND THIS CONVERSATION
BEGAN LAST YEAR A LARGELY IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE ENROLLMENT
CHALLENGES THAT THAT COLLEGES
WERE FACING. BUT ALSO.
GIVEN THE OF THE ADOPTION OF
THE VISION FOR SUCCESS BY OUR
BOARD OF GOVERNORS SO THIS
CONVERSATION IN OUR SYSTEM BEGAN
UP PRIOR TO THE RELEASE OF THE
JANUARY BUDGET. OF THAT GROUP
HAS CONTINUED TO THINK THROUGH
WHAT IS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
MEAN FOR THE SYSTEM.
BOB UPON RELEASE OF BIRD JANUARY
BUDGET.
CHANCELLOR OAK WE ASK THE
PRESIDENT OF.
WE GET A POLICE CEO BOARD TO
CONVENE A WORKGROUP TED TO
CONSIDER THE PROPOSAL AMANAT
BACK GROUP HAS BEEN MEETING
THROUGHOUT.
OVER THE PERIOD OF TIME SINCE
THE RELEASE OF THE BUDGET.
WE HAVE A CONSULTATION COUNCIL
WHICH ARM. IS ESTABLISHED UP
PURSUANT TO EXISTING LAW BUT
INCLUDE STAKEHOLDERS FROM ACROSS
THE SYSTEM ADMINISTRATORS
FACULTY STAFF STUDENTS AND
OTHERS. BOB THAT HAVE BEEN
REVIEWING IT OF THIS PROPOSAL UP
THERE MEETINGS BOTH IN FEBRUARY
AND MARCH.
BUT THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY WE HELD A SERIES OF
EVENTS FOCUSED ON.
HOW DO WE THINK ABOUT EQUITY IN
THE CONVERSATION?
AROUND IN THE FUNDING FORMULA
AND HOW DO WE.
ENCOURAGE OUR GOALS AROUND
EQUITY UP THROUGH THIS
CONVERSATION AND THAT WE'VE
DISTRIBUTED TO SURVEYS ONE ON
THE FUNDING FORMULA AND ONE ON
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS TO OUT TO
GET ADDITIONAL FEEDBACK IN FOR
BOTH OF THOSE HE RECEIVED.
HUNDREDS OF RESPONSES.
AND SO IS WORTH BANKING THROUGH
OUR NEXT STEPS I THINK WE ARE
PLANNING TO TAKE THE FEEDBACK
THAT WE'VE HEARD OF THE FEEDBACK
FROM THE LEADERSHIP IN OUR
OFFICE FROM OUR BOARD OF
GOVERNORS. TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THEM ABOUT
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THE MAY
REVISION AND SO WE THINK THAT
THE MAYOR VISION IS A PLACE
WHERE WE CAN BEGIN TO.
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
WE'VE HEARD.
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS.
I TRY TO INCLUDE SOME QUESTIONS
HERE THAT REFLECT ADAM SOME OF
THE WAYS OF SOME OF THE THOUGHTS
THAT HAVE EMERGED IN SOME OF THE
WAYS OF ORGANIZING THIS
CONVERSATION. AND SO AGAIN YOU
KNOW WE AGREE WITH THE GOVERNOR
THAT THE FORMULA SHOULD
RECOGNIZE ACCESS SUCCESS IN
OUTCOMES.
AND SO AS WE MOVE FORWARD HOW
MUCH EMPHASIS SHOULD BE PLACED
ON EACH OF THE THREE COMPONENTS
OF THAT PROPOSAL. AND SO ONE OF
THE AREAS THAT THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE SUGGESTED WE USE THE
SHORTHAND OF ABOUT HALF OF THE
MONEY GOING OUT BASED ON ACT.
BASED ON ENROLLMENT ABOUT A
QUARTER BASED ON THESE MEASURES
OF STUDENT NEED AND THE FINAL
QUARTER BASED ON OUTCOMES. YOU
KNOW I THINK WE'RE HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT BY A WHAT'S
THE RIGHT BALANCE THERE.
THE SECOND BULLET ASKS YOU KNOW
IN A FUNDING FORMULA THAT
PROVIDES RESOURCES HAVE FOR
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR SPOUSE
CERTAIN GROUPS OF STUDENTS. WHAT
CHARACTERISTICS ABOUT MIGHT WE
CONSIDER AND I THINK THE
CONVERSATION WE'VE BEEN HAVING
THEIR IS OTHER CHARACTERISTICS
THAT ARE NOT RELATED TO
FINANCIAL NEED? VETERANS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
LOOK AT.
OTHER THIRD IS AROUND KIND OF
IMPROVED OUTCOMES TO GET OUT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL USES
DEGREES AND CERTIFICATES ARE
THERE OTHER OUTCOMES
PARTICULARLY OUTCOMES RELATED TO
PROGRESSION THAT WE MIGHT WANT
TO ALSO CONSIDER IS THE BASIS
FOR FUNDING.
A FOURTH OF WITH REGARD TO
STABILITY HOW MUCH YEAR OVER
YEAR CHANGE ARE WE COMFORTABLE
IN A DAY FOR FORMULA.
AND THEN FINALLY AS WE
TRANSITION TO A NEW FORMULA WHAT
PERIOD OF TIME IS APPROPRIATE
WHAT TYPE OF HOLD HARMLESS TO WE
NEED TO A DESIGN WAS THAT LOOK
LIKE AND WHAT KIND OF CAPACITY
DO WE NEED IN THE SHORT TERM.
SO I'M HAPPY TO TALK THROUGH THE
WAYS IN WHICH SOME OF THE
GROUPS.
YOU KNOW HAVE TALKED TO THAT.
IF YOU'RE INTERESTED IN THEM
HAVE QUESTIONS.
SO JUST ABOUT TO CLOSE YOU KNOW
I THINK YOU KNOW.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE WANT TO BE
MINDFUL OF IS THAT A NEW FORMULA
DE IN OUR MIND IS INTENDED TO
ENCOURAGE CHANGES THE OTHER
CAMPUSES AND SO. WE NEED TO
THINK THROUGH HOW WE ARE CHOOSE
TO IMPLEMENT THIS.
OBVIOUSLY CHANGES IN STATUTE
WOULD REQUIRE CHANGES IN OUR
SYSTEMS POLICIES THAT OUR
APPORTIONMENT SYSTEMS. AND THEN
REQUIRE US TO COMMUNICATE THOSE
WITH OUR COLLEGES BUT I THINK
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT WE THINK
ABOUT THE TYPE OF ACTIVITIES
THAT WE SHOULD BE TAKING THE
TYPE OF CAPACITY BUILDING THAT
WE SHOULD BE DOING. TO ENCOURAGE
A COLLEGE IS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE INCENTIVES THAT ARE
CREATED IN THE NEW SYSTEM.
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY WE'RE MAKING
A SET OF HYPOTHESES THAT THESE
TYPES OF POLICY CHANGES WILL
RESULT IN IMPROVED OUTCOMES AND
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WE
EVALUATE THE FACTS OF THOSE IN
THE COMING YEARS. AND MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS AND SO THAT
INCLUDES.
WORKING WITH YOU ALL IN COMING
YEARS TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE WERE
FIND THE FORMULA. TO DO WHAT WE
WANTED STIFF.
AND WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS.
OKAY.
QUESTIONS FIRST OF ALL WE'RE NOT
TAKING THE ROLE TODAY THIS IS A
JOINT INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
AND ALSO AND KNOW TO THE TO THE
PUBLIC THAT WE DID TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS ISSUE REMEMBER
LAST TIME BUT IF IF YOU'RE SO
INSPIRED TO WANT TO. ENGAGE
AGAIN AT THAT AT THE END WE
WILL.
WE WILL.
OBLIGED FIRST WILL START WITH
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OUT OF A FEW
BUT OPENED UP TO. MY OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY SURE SO ON I THINK A FEW
QUESTIONS AND AND FOR THOSE MAY
BE IN THE AUDIENCE OR OR ON OR
NOT.
AND IT WAS THE INTENT OF OF THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS HAVE AN ADOPTED YET BUT
COME OUR FEEDBACK.
AND THAT MAY BE GIVE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE PERMANENT
FINANCED IT TO CLARIFY. THAT
SOME OF THE OTHER COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SMALLER CATEGORICAL
STATE.
THE.
HE AT THAT POINT DAY AND NAY
SAYER PIANISSIMO JOB THAT WE
WERE NOT CAN YOU DID DISABILITY
PROGRAMS WE WERE NOT CONSIDERING
THOSE TO BE PART OF THIS FUNDING
FORMULA.
SO THAT IS IS THAT IS THAT
CORRECT.
AND SO THERE'S TWO COMPONENTS SO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AND TERMS OF
AT CHANGING THE FUNDING FORMULA
APPLIES ONLY TO GENERAL PURPOSE
PORTION MEN'S. WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET CALLS FOR IS
FOR THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO
ENGAGE WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND SEE
OF HIS OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN THE
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS TO? PROVIDE
MORE FLEXIBILITY AS WE DON'T
HAVE ANY AT AT THIS POINT WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT SPECIFIC
CATEGORIC WAS YOU WANNA HEAR
FEEDBACK FAIR CHANCE HIS OFFICE
MAYBE COMMITTEE COLLEGES CAN
CLARIFY BUT AS WHEN I. MAKE SURE
THAT WE KNOW THAT THAT WE SO FAR
HAVE THAT.
THE IN ITS COLLECTIVE INTENT
THAT WE WILL MAKE SURE THAT
CLARIFY THAT'S NOT PART OF THE
DISCUSSION MEAN LOOKING AT THE
THREE BIG POTS OF MAYBE YES SO I
THINK YOU KNOW. THE GOVERNOR'S
REQUEST WAS LOOK AT CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS OUT WE HAVE NOT HEARD
SUGGESTIONS BUT THOSE ARE PLACES
THAT WE SHOULD LOOK. OUT TO YOUR
POINT WE'VE BEEN FOCUSING ON THE
STUDENT.
SUCCESS IN SUPPORT PROGRAM THE
STUDENT EQUITY PROGRAM AND THE
BASIC SKILLS INITIATIVE WHICH
ARE SIZE WILL.
AMOUNTS OF MONEY THAT WE THINK.
WE CAN CHANGE INCENTIVES THERE.
THERE AND AND THAT BE THE THAT
WHAT THE PROPOSAL THAT WE SEND
OUR THE RECOMMENDATION WE SEND
BACK WITH PART OF FINANCES I
THINK THE MESSAGE GOT NOW. WE
DON'T SEE DOZENS OF THEM.
KNOWLEDGE AND TWENTY STUDENTS IN
THE AUDIENCE HERE TODAY SO. I
THAT NUMBER ONE IN THE NUMBER
TWO I I DO ASSUME THAT YOU'RE
TAKING THIS COLLECTIVE FEEDBACK
IN THE NAY REVISION YOU'LL TAKE
THESE THINGS INTO CONSIDERATION
WITH THAT REVISION FOR THE. WITH
THAT REVISED PROPOSAL FOR THIS.
SO I CAN SPEAK WITH CERTAINTY ON
A WELL ONLY NOW BEING HEARD AND.
YOU KNOW INCLUDE IN THE IN THE
MAYOR VISION BUT WE ARE
CERTAINLY ENGAGING THEM WITH
STAKEHOLDERS WITH THE RECEIVING
FEEDBACK ARE DEATHLY TAKING THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION.
OKAY. AND THEN AS FAR AS THE ON.
THE HOLD HARMLESS ISSUE I KNOW
I'VE HEARD FROM A FEW COMMUNITY
COLLEGES NOT JUST.
AND.
IN IN MY DISTRICT UT FROM
ACROSS THE STATE AND. AND I I
THINK THAT.
IS SOMETHING THAT THAT WE OUGHT
TO TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT WE DID
WITH LCF F..
THAT WE DIDN'T NECESSARILY PICK
WINNERS AND LOSERS SOME MAY SAY
NO WE'RE HAVING DEBATES IN K.
TWELVE THAT THERE ARE THAT
BITES.
YOU KNOW AS WE GROW GOING
FORWARD THE NEW REVENUES NOT
AFTER ONE OR TWO YEARS.
TO TEN SEE RE BAD SHOULD HAVE
ONE OF THOSE DISTRICTS TAKEN A
SIGNIFICANT.
I HAD SO I THINK THAT'S THAT'S
IMPORTANT.
.
TO TO ME I THINK TO TO TO PICK
SUBCOMMITTEE SO FAR SIDES WANNA
MAKE SURE WE WE HAVE THAT.
ON THE RECORD. AND THEN.
AT AND THEN AT SO I THINK THE
DEBATE IS WE KNOW WHAT WHAT
BUCKETS OF.
.
AB ANYWAY TALKING ABOUT THE
GENERAL. KIND IT IMPORT CEMENT
WHICH IS IN THE COMPARISON TRADE
LIKE K. TWELVE.
JUST MEAN UPPER PEOPLE.
AND THEN LOOKING AT SOME TAPPED
A DEMOGRAPHIC. CHARACTERISTICS
INCOME AND THEN THE ARM AND THE.
.
THE OUTCOME SPEAKS AND SO I KNOW
THAT TWO CRITICISMS HAVE COME UP
IN THE LAST FEW MONTHS I WANT TO
GIVE BACK COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO TO
RESPOND.
AND TO THOSE AND SO AS FAR AS
THE OUTCOMES BASED.
YOU KNOW ONE OF THAT ONE OF THE
CRITICISMS IS THAT.
IT WOULD JUST IT WOULD
ESSENTIALLY BE AT M. ANALOGOUS
TO WHAT HAPPENS IN K. TWELVE AND
TESTING THAT.
THAT.
YOU KNOW YOUR REWARD SCHOOLS
FOR.
TESTING AND NOT TEACHING AND
INCENTIVIZE IS DIFFERENT TACK
BEHAVIOR IN THOSE.
THOSE I ON OUTCOMES ARE OUT OF
THAT SOMETIMES OUT OF THE REACH
OF THE PEOPLE TO TEACH A
CLASSROOM AND SO I'M YOU KNOW WE
DON'T ALWAYS. PAY TEACHERS BY
PERFORMANCE AND HOW THEY'RE YOU
KNOW THE OUTCOMES OF OF THE
STUDENTS.
AND AND THEN TO IT IF YOU HAD
SOME TYPE OF FORMULA BASED UPON.
OUTCOMES
COM YOU KNOW WOULD IT BE A
DISADVANTAGE TO CERTAIN SCHOOLS
THAT MAYBE DON'T HAVE THE BEST
OUTCOMES.
YOU KNOW THERE IS A HIGH
ACHIEVING SCHOOL THAT HAS
TREMENDOUS TRANSFER RATES AND.
CERTIFICATES
HOW ARE THEY GONNA BE REWARDED
WITH THE WHOLE NOTION OF THIS IS
WE WANT TO GIVE RESOURCES TO THE
SCHOOLS. HAS STUDENTS WHO NEED
THE MOST HELP SELL.
MAYBE YOU CAN START OFF BY
RESPONDING TO IT TO TO HAVE THAT
OF THE CRITICISMS AS FAR AS.
THE AT IMPLEMENTATION.
SURE SO.
ON THE CONCERNS ABOUT ALL OUT
QUALITY I THINK AS AND THAT LEO
MENTIONED.
ME OF THE RESEARCH IS
INCONCLUSIVE ON WHETHER OUT
QUALITY ADD DECREASES AND.
IT IN INSTANCES WHERE
PERFORMANCE SPACE OUT BECAUSE
HE'S FUNNY MODELS HAVE BEEN
ADOPTED SO THERE'S STRONG
EVIDENCE THAT FACULTY WILL NOT
LOWER STANDARDS I THINK ONE OF
THE. CONCERNS HAS BEEN BROUGHT
UP IS SAYS INCREASE OF
CERTIFICATES A SHORT TERM
CERTIFICATES IN THE FUNNY MODEL
AND WE'VE CRAFTED THE LANGUAGE
THERE. TO ENSURE THAT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE CONTINUES TO
MONITOR AND.
TO DEVELOP STANDARDS FOR THE AT
METRICS ARE COUNTED AS PART OF
THE OF THE FUNDING FORMULA WE
HAVE BEEN TAKING FEEDBACK ON YOU
KNOW THINKING THROUGH THOSE.
POLITY ISSUES.
IN TERMS OF SORT OF A FUNDING
FORMULA PENALIZING AT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAT THAT SERVE LOW
INCOME STUDENTS. I THINK THE KEY
IS REALLY FINDING THAT BALANCE I
THINK WE WANNA HAVE A STRONG
COMPONENT OF RESOURCES TO THOSE
DISTRICTS THAT SERVED AND
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS SO WE
CRAFTED.
A FORMULA THAT TRAVIS TRIES TO
STRIKE THAT BALANCE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO DRECK RESOURCES TO
THOSE COLLEGES THAT'S HURDLES
POPULATIONS BUT IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO CREATE THE
INCENTIVES.
TO TO FURTHER.
THE STUDENT SUCCESS EFFORTS
THAT ARE HAPPENING.
AT THE COLLEGES SO WE'RE
DEATHLY THINKING THROUGH THAT
BALANCE AND ONE OF THE. COMET
PIECES OF FEEDBACK HAS BEEN IS
OUR WAY TO BETTER INCORPORATE
EQUITY INTO THE STUDENT SUCCESS
INCENTIVE GRANT TO WE ARE TAKING
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION AS PART
OF THIS A LARGER RESPONSE TO HOW
DO WE ENSURE. THAT THE DISTRICTS
A SERB.
LOW INCOME POPULATIONS ARE
RECEIVING IN THE RESOURCES AND
ARE BEING REWARDED FOR.
IMPROVING OUTCOMES FOR THOSE
POPULATIONS.
AND DAD CAN YOU GO BACK TO THE
ISSUE THAT I RAISED EARLIER
ABOUT THE. DISTRICTS CONCERNED
ABOUT THE.
GOING FORWARD THE NEW ENGLAND
HOLDING HARMLESS.
I'M OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM.
I SURE SO IT THINK THAT'S
ANOTHER CONVERSATION THAT WE'VE
BEEN YOU KNOW HEARING FEEDBACK
ON.
YOU KNOW AND THERE'S THERE'S AN
ONGOING HOLD HARMLESS THAT WE
PROPOSE AND THERE'S.
IN US THERE'S VARIOUS
COMPONENTS TO THAT BUT I'M IN
THINKING THROUGH THE TRANSITION
TO THE NEW FORMULA WE THINK THAT
AS FEES RATES INCREASE THAT
THOSE DISTRICTS THAT WOULD BE
HELD HARMLESS IN THE FIRST
YEARS.
WOULD QUICKLY TRANSITION INTO.
AT THE NEW FORMULA THAT THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
DEATHLY LOOKING INTO THAT
TRANSITION PERIOD BUT OF THE
GOAL IS REALLY TO HAVE DISTRICTS
MOVED TO THE CITY A FUNDING
FORMULA AND YOU ALLOCATION. AWAY
FROM THE HOLD HARMLESS SO THAT
BE JUST THROUGH THAT FIRST
COUPLE YEARS OF A TRANSITION AND
THEN YOU WOULD RIVER.
TO THAT TO THE NEW FORMULA
POURED. ALL GOING FORWARD NEW
MONEY SOAK.
NEW MONEY WOULD BE PART OF THAT
NEW FORMULA AT THE HOLD HARMLESS
IS AN ON GOING HOME HOLD
HARMLESS THAT IS TIED TO
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN.
PURSUED AND RATES.
IF I'D JUST ON THE OUTCOMES PART
OF THIS SITE I DO WANT TO SEE
YOU KNOW I THINK.
PART OF THE CONVERSATION WE'RE
HAVING A CERTAIN ABOUT HOW DO WE
STRIKE A BALANCE ACROSS A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT VALUES. I
THINK THE POINT OF THE VISION
FOR SUCCESS OR ONE OF THE.
KEY PARTS OF THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS IS AN ACKNOWLEDGEMENT
THAT OUR OUTCOMES TODAY ARE
WHERE WE WOULD LIKE THEM TO BE
SO I THINK. A GREATER EMPHASIS
ON OUTCOMES IN OUR MIND IT I
THINK IS A WELCOME PART OF THIS
FORMULA WHEN PEOPLE TALK ABOUT.
.
GUIDED PATHWAYS THE METAPHOR.
FOLKS OFTEN USES.
MOVING FROM A CAFETERIA STYLE.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE EXPERIENCE
WHERE THE PRIMARY VALUE IS ON
BROAD ACCESS TO A VARIETY OF
COURSES.
SHIFTING INTO A MORE FOCUS
PATHWAY WHERE STUDENTS ARE GIVEN
OR ARE ASKED WHAT THEIR
EDUCATIONAL GOALS ARE AND ARE
GIVEN A DIRECTION.
TO GET THERE AND SO I THINK.
.
YOU KNOW I THINK WE WE WILL NEED
TO SEE IF A.
PUTTING THIS IN A FUNDING
FORMULA TAKES US
FAR LEADS TO.
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES BUT I
THINK.
YOU KNOW PART OF THIS IS.
ALL WHINING OUR FUNDING SYSTEM
WITH THE EXPECTATIONS WE'VE SET
OUT.
TO THE POINT ABOUT.
ACCESS FOR ON YOU KNOW STUDENTS
WHO HAVE HISTORICALLY BEEN
UNDERSERVED OR WHOSE
CHARACTERISTICS SUGGEST THAT.
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE A HARDER
TIME MEETING THE OUTCOMES THAT
WE.
INCLUDING A FORMULA YOU KNOW I
THINK THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
NOTED THAT ONE WAY YOU CAN
DESIGN A FORMULA AND IN A PLACE
WHERE WE'VE SEEN SOME
PRELIMINARY EVIDENCE IN OTHER
STATES THAT THIS HELPS TO
ALLEVIATE THOSE CONCERNS. IS BY.
INCLUDING ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR THE OUTCOMES ATTRIBUTABLE TO
CERTAIN GROUPS AND SO LOOKING
AT.
DEGREES EARNED A BY LOW INCOME
STUDENTS I THINK THAT'S A OR
SOMETHING REASONABLE AND AND
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BE
I'VE BEEN THINKING ABOUT
INTERNALLY.
WELL I WOULDA I WAS GONNA
IMPLIED THAT THAT ISSUE ABOUT
THE OUTCOMES OF THE GREAT NOW
YOU SEE HIM LIKE THAT THAT THE
DATA RUN THAT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCED PRODUCED.
YOU LOOKING AT OUTCOMES THAT ARE
NOT CONTROLLING FOR THE
DEMOGRAPHIC FACTORS I THINK ONCE
YOU'VE. DESIGNED A SYSTEM THAT
DOES THAT I THINK YOU YOU THE.
YEAR LOW UNIT YOU ELIMINATE THE
ISSUE OF SERVE PENALIZING.
GOT DISTRICTS THAT HAVE OUR
POPULATIONS THAT ARE HARDER TO
SERVE SO WE THINK THAT THE ONE.
KEY WAY THAT YOU COULDN'T
ADDRESS THAT COMPONENT. ON ON ON
THE WHOLE ARE MUCH OF THE GETS
ITS ACT.
IF THE CHALLENGING ISSUE ON THE
ONE HAND YOU WANT TO PROVIDE
SOME STABILITY FOR. A NURSE FOR
COLLEGES AND COMMITTEE BECAUSE
DISTRICTS OF THE TRANSITIONING
AT THE SAME TIME EVENTUALLY YOU
DO WANT THIS TO MATTER BECAUSE
THE WHOLE POINT IS THAT THE
FORMULA FOR BOTH TO CREATE AN
INCENTIVE. DIRECTED TO CHANGE
BEHAVIOR AND SO I THINK THAT FOR
A DIFFICULT TRADE OFF AND KIND
OF FIGURE OUT HOW TO BALANCE
THAT.
PROVIDING SOME STABILITY WHAT
THE SAME TIME ENSURING THAT THE
THE FORMULA ITSELF. HAVE AN
EFFECT I'M I'M ON BOOK COLLEGES
RECEIVE.
MISTER CHAVEZ.
I'M A VERY INTRIGUED BY THIS
WHOLE EFFORT WE'RE DOING HERE I
THINK IT'S.
THE LA TIMES STUDY LOOKING AT IT
AND I'D LIKE TO.
GOING BACK TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES FARMS HOW MANY STUDENTS
WHO ACTUALLY TRANSFERRED IS USE
YOUR USUALLY.
WE KNOW THAT THE.
.
WHO?
I THINK THE CAFETERIA MODEL YOU
LAID OUT IS PROBABLY APPROPRIATE
THAT PEOPLE TAKE A LOT OF THINGS
BUT YOU KIND OF WONDER AND FOR
WHAT AND TO WHAT END.
.
MAKES YOU THINK BACK WHEN I
WOULD TO A JUNIOR COLLEGE.
BEFORE I BECAME A COMMITTEE
COLLEGE WAS VERY SH SCRIPTED
WITH THE IDEA THAT YOU WOULD GO
THERE AND YOU WERE GOING TO
TRANSFER TO A. SERIOUS YOU GET A
PATHWAY HE HAS VERY CLEAR LOT A
COUNSELING.
SOMEWHERE I THINK WE GOT OFF
THAT.
.
YOU MENTIONED THAT DID. THAT THE
CURRENT MODEL DISCOURAGES
INNOVATION.
THAT THE ECONOMICS OF THE STATE.
WHEN WE HAVE OF ROBUST ECONOMY
THE AROMA DROPS WE HAVE MORE
MONEY BUT WE HAVE.
STRUGGLING ECONOMY WITH PEOPLE
TRYING TO RETRAIN.
WE HAVE A DROP IN THE MONEY AND
THAT'S WHY MORE PEOPLE THERE.
SO THIS SHOULD.
COULD ADDRESS IT.
AND THEN YOU TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW
WHAT IS ACTUALLY THE GOAL OF THE
STATE AND THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM AND THAT WAS. EDUCATION.
ARE PREPARED FOR WORKFORCE.
I THINK DOES A REALLY GOOD
POINT SOME WHY WE NEED TO DO
THIS.
I THINK.
THERE'S SOME GOOD THINGS HERE.
NOW AND. I DON'T THINK I HEARD A
LOT OF DISCUSSION OR MAYBE YOU
COULD TALK TO ME ABOUT.
THE RURAL COMMUNITIES.
I MAY LOSE SIGNIFICANT FUNDING I
HAVE A QUESTION HERE.
HOW DOESTHE ADMINISTRATION PLAN?
TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF WORLD
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THEY EXPRESSED THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO BE RELEASING FUNDING.
SO WHAT'S YOUR THOUGHT ABOUT
RURAL KING COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND HOW WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
CARE.
CHRIS FORGET SOME OF FINANCE SO
CERTAIN WE WE'VE HEARD THOSE
SAME CONCERNS.
CHAU AS WE'RE LOOKING AT
DIFFERENT FACTORS AND FEEDBACK
THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM THE FIELD.
WILL CERTAINLY TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION I THINK ONE OF THE
MOST COMMON ELEMENTS THAT WE'VE
HEARD FROM WORLD COLLEGES TO
CONSIDER. IF THERE'S A
PARTICULAR COMPONENT UP REFERRED
TO AS THE BASE ALLOCATION IN THE
FORMULA. AND IF THAT.
USING THE RIGHT BANDS AND THE
RIGHT WAITS TO CAPTURE SOME OF
THOSE BASIC NECESSITIES THAT AT
THOSE TYPES OF COLLEGES.
I'M SO IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
CERTAINLY HEARD FROM DISTRICTS
AND SOMETHING THAT WERE
CERTAINLY.
CONSIDERING AND LOOKING UP.
IT.
I WOULD JUST ADD THAT I.
YOU KNOW I THINK OFTEN WHEN WE
ARE CONSIDERING HER BECAUSE
WE'VE BEEN ENGAGED IN THIS
PROCESS OF CONSIDERING A NEW
FORMULA I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT A
COMPARATIVE WHAT WE HAVE IN
PLACE TODAY BUT I THINK.
YOU KNOW A THE CHALLENGES THAT
RURAL COMMUNITY SPACE ARE OFTEN
CHALLENGES HAVE. YOU KNOW.
.
INSUFFICIENT ECONOMIES OF SCALE
THAT I THINK ARE SIMILAR
CHALLENGES AND AND ENROLLMENT
FUNDING SYSTEM AND I THINK YOU
CAN IMAGINE THAT YOU KNOW. A
SOME OF THESE CHALLENGES MIGHT
BE ALLEVIATED IN A SYSTEM THAT
ISN'T SO BASED ON C. TIME BUT IS
BASED ON KINDS OF THE TYPES OF
OUTCOMES. AND IN SOME CASES HERE
I THINK DEPENDING ON HOW YOU
DEFINE WHICH STUDENT GROUPS.
ARE IMPORTANT TO.
TARGETING A FORMULA I THINK YOU
CAN ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE
CONCERNS TO SO I THINK THIS IS.
.
YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S
FEEDBACK THAT WE'VE HEARD ALSO
THAT WE HAVE.
TAKEN YOU KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT BUT I DON'T
THINK WE SHOULD FUNDAMENTAL
FUNDAMENTALLY IMAGINE THAT RURAL
COMMUNITIES.
WOULD DO WE WOULD HAVE TO
ACCOMMODATE THEM IN AN INFORMAL
I THINK IN MANY WAYS.
THAT YOU KNOW WE CAN WE CAN
DESIGN BENEFITS THAT ARE BETTER
THAN WHAT OF THE CURRENT SYSTEM
PROVIDES FOR SOME OF THESE
COLLEGES.
WHAT TYPE OF BENEFITS?
WE THINK SO I THINK YOU KNOW THE
TWO COMPONENTS YOU KNOW THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY THIS ARE YOU KNOW THE
PORTION OF THIS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION CALLS A BASE
GRANT.
YOU KNOW THIS.
FINANCE SUGGESTED.
THAT IS A COMBINATION OF PER
FTE YES FUNDING AND.
PER COLLEGE PER DISTRICT
FUNDING SO I THINK.
FIGURING OUT WHAT THE RELATIVE
SHARE OF THOSE TWO PARTS OF THAT
YOU KNOW ARE IMPORTANT COME.
CONVERSATION I THINK AS WE
THINK ABOUT THE SUPPLEMENTAL
SIDE OF THIS THEN IT'S HOW DO
YOU DEFINE.
WHICH STUDENTS WERE TARGETING
IN THE FORMULA AND I THINK ON
THE OUTCOME SIDE OF THIS.
I THINK WE NEED TO YOU KNOW
PART OF THIS IS LOOKING AT WHAT
IS THE RATIO OF THE COLLEGES
OUTCOMES TO ITS.
ENROLLMENT AND HOW DO WE YOU
KNOW IN SOME CASES I'M CERTAIN.
A CERTAIN OUTCOMES THAT WE
CHOOSE OUR MIGHT ACTUALLY MAKE
SENSE I MAKE MORE SENSE AND.
CONNECT CONTEXT COMPARED TO
ENROLLMENT.
NOT JUST MY CONCERN IS YOU KNOW
COMMUNITY COLLEGES
BECAUSE YOU SEE. A REAL ECONOMIC
ENGINES IN A COMMUNITY AND MANY
TIMES IN THERE AND A RURAL
AREAS.
YOU KNOW THE. IN THOSE LOWER
COST OF LIVING THEY OFTEN HAVE.
STRUGGLING FOR JOBS AND THINGS
SO. I JUST HAVE THAT CONCERNED
ON THE ROAD COLLEGES.
I'M NOT THE LA GO THEY HAVE THIS
LAST BULLET HERE MONITOR
IMPLEMENTATION DETERMINE IF
NEGATIVE OUTCOMES.
EMERGE HOW DO YOU SEE THAT.
WHEN WILL YOU START SAY IN. HOW
DID YOU GUYS CAN BE REPORTED
BACK TO US ON THE IMPACT OF THIS
DECISION?
WHAT BINGO A LOT OF THE THE
INFORMATION THAT WE ARE
RECOMMENDING THE CHAPTERS OFFICE
ALREADY COLLECT THAT INFORMATION
AND AND?
HAS IT AVAILABLE WHAT'S MORE
ABOUT MINORING OVER THE NEXT FEW
YEARS AND I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE
RIGHT AMOUNT OF TIME TO THE
DEPARTING RELEASED A FEW YEARS
OF INFORMATION. TO COME TO GET A
SENSE OF THERE'S A TREND GOING
ON BUT I THINK IT'S JUST LOOKING
AT THINGS LIKE ARE WE SEEING OF
THIS CONCERN ABOUT SHIFTING TO
SHORT TERM CERTIFICATES ARE WE
SEEING THEIR THE SYSTEM AS A
WHOLE. THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OVEREMPHASIS ON THAT OR A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE ON THAT
VERSUS OTHER. OTHER.
AT DEGREES OR CERTIFICATES DO
WE SEE OUR DIFFERENCES IN
OUTCOMES FOR THE GROUND WITH
WITH DIFFERENT UP PARTICULAR
STUDENT GROUPS.
I THINK IT'S IT'S NOW OF
SOMETHING THAT WE THINK YOU'RE
GONNA SAY FIND THE THE EXACT
PROBLEM OF YUGOSLAVIA BUT
MONITORING THAT DATA CAN HELP
YOU GET A SENSE OF WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THE SYSTEM. AS LONG AS
ALSO OBVIOUSLY HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH.
WITH COLLEGES ADMINISTRATORS
FACULTY ON WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
STUDENTS TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
YOU HAVE A GOOD SENSE OF. HOW
THINGS ARE CHANGING IN THE
SYSTEM BUT WE THINK IT'S ONE
IMPORTANT WAY TO ENSURE THAT?
I'M MORE LOOKING AT WHAT'S GOING
ON AND IF THERE ARE SOME THINGS
THAT HAPPEN THAT ARE.
OR ISSUES THAT WE DIDN'T WE
DIDN'T WANT TO CARVE OUT THERE
COULD BE SOME.
THOUGHT TO HOW WE MIGHT WANT TO
MAKE CHANGES IN THE SYSTEM TO
ADDRESS THEM.
MY CONCERN IS A YOU KNOW WE
START LOW CONTROL FUNDING. SIX
YEARS AGO. OF YOU KNOW WE HAD TO
DEVELOP THE EL CAP WE HAD TO.
FIGURE OUT THE DASHBOARD.
IT CHANGED THE.
THE WHOLE CULTURE IN SCHOOLS
NOT JUST SOMETHING CONTROLLED BY
SUPERINTENDENT BUT THE COMMUNITY
AND PARENTS AND KIDS AND.
AND REALLY CHANGED.
.
THE INVOLVEMENT A COMMUNITY FOR
OUR KATIE TWELVE RIGHT AND I
THINK ALL THOSE ARE GOOD. BUT TO
WAIT SIX YEARS NOW.
ARE AND WE'RE TRYING TO CHANGE
THE CULTURE NICK UNICOLOR
DISTRICT POLICE TO.
A MONETARY SYSTEM I THINK THAT'S
GOING TO TAKE LONG TIME SO DO
THE.
TO THE CHANCELLOR.
.
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO MANAGE THIS
CHANGE IN?
YOU KNOW I I MADE A COMMENT BACK
WE STARTED SIX YEARS AGO OF
LOCAL FUNDING AS IT IS COULD
TAKE FOUR TO SIX YEARS TO GET
THIS THING ALONE.
COULD YOU DON'T.
WE HAD A LIGHT SWITCH OF PEOPLE
THOUSAND CHANGE.
IN OTHER GOING TO THINK HOW THEY
USED TO DO IT SO.
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO MANAGE THE
CHANGE WITHIN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES OF WE DO THIS?
AND I THINK THAT'S THEY ARE YOU
KNOW I I MENTION CAPACITY
BUILDING I THINK THAT TAKES A
LOT OF FORMS.
BUT I WOULD SAY THANK YOU KNOW
WE ARE RAMPING UP THOSE EFFORTS.
GENERALLY I THINK THE.
PART OF CHANCELLOR OAKLEY'S
VISION IS THAT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
PLAYS A MORE CENTRAL ROLE IN
SUPPORTING STUDENT SUCCESS IN
THE SYSTEM ARM. SO I THINK THERE
ARE THERE BEEN.
YOU NO LONGER EFFORTS.
THE AYE IP AYE INSTITUTIONAL
EFFECTIVENESS PARTNERSHIP WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING I THINK IS ONE
WAY WE'VE DONE IT.
IN RECENT YEARS I THINK THE
GUIDED PATHWAYS WORK OF
SUPPORTING COLLEGES AND
IMPLEMENTING GUIDED PATHWAYS IS
A MODEL BUT I THINK WE CAN.
THINK ABOUT MOVING FORWARD
THOSE CONVERSATIONS I THINK OUR
PRELIMINARY BUT I.
.
I THINK WE ARE COMMITTED AND WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT A PART OF
MAKING SURE A SYSTEM LIKE THIS
WORKS IS THAT. COLLEGES KNOW HOW
TO TAKE THE.
YOU KNOW TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
INCENTIVES THAT CREATES SO I
THINK THAT INVOLVES WORK FROM
OUR OFFICE IN THAT INVOLVES
WORK.
FROM THE SYSTEM AND THINKING
THROUGH.
HOW DO WE TAKE SUCCESSFUL
PRACTICES IN ONE CONTEXT AND
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
AVAILABLE TO THE COLLEGES
ELSEWHERE?
ARE YOU SETTING UP A SEPARATE
ORGANIZATION STRUCTURE HOT. HOW
YOU DOING THIS YET THE LOTTERY
WORDS RIGHT THERE BUT I'M SURE I
THINK I'M HARD I GRABBED ON?
GUIDED PATHWAYS WOULD BE ONE
EXAMPLE THAT I THINK WE HAVE
PROVIDED.
SO ONE TIME RESOURCES
LEGISLATUREAPPROVED ONE TIME
RESOURCES LAST YEAR OUR OFFICE
HAS BEEN SUPPORTING THAT WE
OFTEN AND THROUGHOUT A LOT OF
THIS WORK.
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE EXPERTISE
OF COLLEGES THE INSTITUTIONAL
EFFECTIVENESS WORK IS LARGELY IN
MANY CASES PEER DRIVEN BUT IT'S
COLLEGES SUPPORTING OTHER
COLLEGES AND ADVANCING CHANGE.
SO I DON'T.
YOU KNOW I I THINK IT WOULD BE
PRELIMINARY WE DON'T WE HAVEN'T
PROPOSED ANY TYPE OF NEW
STRUCTURE BUT I THINK WE.
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT CENTRALLY OUR
OFFICE NEEDS TO PLAY A ROLE.
YOU'RE YOU CARRY BACK HIS
CHANCES ARE I.
I LIKE TO HEAR THE DISCUSSION I
WAS GONNA MANAGE CHANGE THAT IS
LISTEN ALLOCATE TO OUR WE HAD A
THOUSAND SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS
THE STATE. HERE'S ONE GOVERNANCE
BODY AND IF INDEED DO SOME LIKE
THIS TRAINS.
THE CULTURE.
.
HAVE YOU UP WHEN I READ MY STATE
AGENCY AND I WAS CHANGING AT.
YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF.
.
RESPECT YOU HAVE TO GIVE TO YOUR
EMPLOYEES. TO GET THEM TO WHERE
YOU WANT TO GO GET. INTO THIS
THIS IS A VERY SIGNIFICANT.
CHANGE I GUESS OF MY LAST COMING
TO BE. AS I WAS LOOKING THIS
ABOUT TALKING MY STAFF ON ITS IT
ESSENTIALLY.
WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING IN THE
PAST WHAT HAS BEEN WORKING VERY
WELL IN THIS IN THIS IS A COMMON
THERE? MANY BUREAUCRACIES THAT
WE REWARD ACTIVITIES.
YOU KNOW WE WERE GIVEN MONEY FOR
PEOPLE TO DO STUFF.
AND THAT'S A FAILURE.
WE'VE LEARNED A LONG TIME AGO
THAT IT'S BETTER TO REWARD
RESULTS.
NOT JUST ACTIVITIES BUT RESULTS
AND SO. WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS CHANGE THE CULTURE OF THE
COMMUNICABLE JUST THINK THAT?
THAT'S A GOOD THING.
YOU NO M. BUSINESSES BEEN THERE
AS LONG TIME. YOU NOTE.
NOT WE WHAT ACTIVITIES BUT.
RESULTS SOB I'M EXCITED ABOUT IT
I WISH I COULD BE AROUND IS SIX
YEARS HE WAS GOING TO HAPPEN TO
IT BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO TAKE
YOU OUT.
SOME TIME TO GET THERE BUT DATA.
WE DO KNOW THIS WORD WE HAVE
SOME BIG GAPS WERE NOT EETING
SO I APPLAUD TO GOVERNOR EVER.
TAKEN THIS ON IN.
CHANCELLOR'S NEW THEREIN.
WE'LL SEE HOW GRAY HIS HAIR GETS
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS
TRYING TO DO THIS THING.
THANKS.
MR MEDINA THANK YOU. FIRST OF
ALL LET ME THINK OF THE CHAIR
MCCARTY FOR. HAVING THIS ON THE
AGENDA.
.
IT WAS FIRST BROUGHT FORWARD IN
JANUARY WE'RE NOW IN MARCH.
AND THE INTENTION IS TO TRY TO
HAVE THIS THROUGH BY JUNE WHEN
THE BUDGET GETS APPROVED.
I I WANT TO REMIND THE
COMMITTEE.
THAT I SERVED THIRTEEN YEARS ON
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE ABOARD
RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BOARD.
AND.
.
AND A TEACHER.
ALSO.
AGAIN THIRTY FOUR YEARS AND I
SAY THAT BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW
ANYTHING MORE COMPLICATED.
THAT I'VE ENCOUNTERED THEN
SCHOOL FUNDING.
OF OR COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
AYE THERE'S SOME OF WHAT I'VE
HEARD HERE THIS AFTERNOON THAT I
AGREE WITH.
BEING ON THE ON THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BOARD FOR THIRTEEN
YEARS.
CERTAINLY.
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES FEEL THE
FRUSTRATION.
THE FRUSTRATION OF NOT SEEN.
COMPLETION
THE FRUSTRATION OF SEEN.
STUDENTS REMAIN. WITHOUT
GETTING A DEGREE OR CERTIFICATE
OR TRANSFER.
THAT THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT'S AN
ISSUE FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO
TO GRAPPLE WITH.
BUT I'M STRUCK AS I SIT HERE OF
THIS AFTERNOON THE VERY LITTLE
DISCUSSION THAT HAS OCCURRED. TO
DATE.
AT LEAST WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
SO A FINAL LEGISLATOR WHO CHAIRS
HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND I'M A LEGISLATOR WHO'S
SERVED THIRTEEN YEARS ON A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND I'M HAVING
A HARD TIME TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
THIS PROPOSAL. IN THE LAST FEW
MONTHS WE'RE GONNA ASK THE
LEGISLATURE.
OF THE HUNDRED TWENTY MEMBERS
MOST OF WHOM DID NOT SPEND. A
THEIR LIFETIME OR A CONSIDERABLE
AMOUNT OF TIME TO VOTE ON
SOMETHING THAT IS VERY
COMPLICATED.
.
WITHOUT A WHOLE LOT OF
INFORMATION.
SO I AYE AYE SURE THAT BECAUSE I
I JUST DON'T KNOW THAT.
SIX MONTHS.
PROVIDE JANUARY TO JUNE IS
ENOUGH TIME FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO REALLY MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS ON SOMETHING SO
IMPORTANT AS THIS.
AYE I AM NOT SURE AND I'VE HEARD
FROM A. COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PRESIDENTS.
FROM THE.
THAT THE SENATE'S.
OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
THAT THEY DON'T FEEL THAT
THEY'VE HAD ENOUGH TIME TO.
TO TO DEAL WITH THIS
I CERTAINLY DON'T FEEL THAT I
HAVE.
SO I I I THINK THIS IS TOO
IMPORTANT A DECISION.
TO MAKE IN SUCH A SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME.
OF YOU KNOW I AM TRYING AS HARD
AS I CAN.
TO TO UNDERSTAND IT AND I'M
HAVING A HARD TIME.
YOU KNOW I'M HAVING A HARD TIME
TRYING THE WAY YOU KNOW I I I I
REALIZE IT'S.
A LOFTY GOAL.
YOU KNOW I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANYONE WHO CARES MORE ABOUT
STUDENTS THAN.
THEN.
.
FOLKS HERE SAID NON THIS DYESS.
BUT I AM STRUCK.
ALSO BY WHAT I'VE SOMETIMES SEEN
IN EDUCATION HOW THE PENDULUM
SWINGS.
IN EDUCATION.
YOU NO THAT THAT THAT WE GO FROM
ONE TO ANOTHER.
AND I AGAIN WOULD ASK WHERE ARE
THE FACTS
WORDS WERE IS THE DATA WHERE IS
THE DATA BECAUSE WE'VE ALREADY
HEARD GOOD QUESTIONS.
ABOUT.
YOU KNOW HOW HOW DO WE KNOW. YOU
KNOW WHAT ARE THE IT WOULD AGAIN
BE THE CONSEQUENCES TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT.
FOR.
.
RESULTS.
YOU KNOW AYE ICE I TAUGHT IN A
CONTINUATION HIGH SCHOOL I
TAUGHT IN A HIGH SCHOOL WHERE I
WILL TELL YOU.
YOU NO I I I I DON'T THINK THAT
IT IS.
OUT OF THOSE ROUND OF
POSSIBILITIES THAT SCHOOL
SOMETIMES.
A DISCOURAGE STUDENTS
FROM COMING TO SCHOOL.
I'M TED STATES.
SOME STUDENTS ARE DISCOURAGED
AND AGAIN I'VE HEARD FROM
FACULTY.
THAT THEY WOULD BE PRESSURE TO.
GIVE GRADES.
SO AYE I AM I AM I AM JUST VERY
MUCH STRUCK BY THE THE TIME
FRAME. OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO HERE. AND US AND SAY WOULD
AND ASKED THE QUESTION WHAT. IS
THE HURRY SO LET ME ASK THAT
QUESTION WHAT IS THE VERY WHY
ARE WE TRYING TO DO THOSE SO
QUICKLY.
SO. YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WHAT WE'VE BEEN HEARING AND
ENGAGING WITH.
IT DISTRICTS IS A CURRENT MODEL
IS JUST NOT WORKING AND LOOKING
AT.
AT THE RAISING COSTS AND
LOOKING AT A ROMAN TRANSIT
THERE'S A LOT OF VOLATILITY AND
THE EXISTING MODEL AND MAKES IT
VERY DIFFICULT FOR COLLEGES.
ADDS TO PLAN SO THIS IS A
CONCERN THAT WE'VE WE'VE BEEN
HEARING.
AT AT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. AND
WE THINK THAT.
AT THIS MOMENT AYE THIS IT IS
IMPORTANT TO ALIGN THE FUNDING
STRUCTURES AND THE INCENTIVES.
TO FURTHER ENHANCE AND SUPPORT
AT THE STUDENT SUCCESS WORK THAT
IS HAPPENING A CURRENTLY WITH
GUIDED PATHWAYS WIT AB SEVEN OH
FIVE AND RE SHIFTING THE
INCENTIVES AND THE GOAL IS TO
THINK ABOUT NOT JUST ONE FACTOR
ENROLLMENT.
BUT THINKING ABOUT AS STUDENT
SUCCESS
AND ALIGNING THE FISCAL
INCENTIVES WAYS.
THE STUDENT SUCCESS EFFORTS
THAT ARE HAPPENING SO WE THINK
THAT THIS IS THE NEXT STEP ON
FURTHERING AND HAD SEEN THAT
WORK I'M WE HEAR YOUR CONCERNS
AND WE'VE BEEN THINKING ABOUT.
BEING THOUGHTFUL ABOUT THE
TRANSITION.
TO THE NEW FUNDING FORMULA
WE'VE INCLUDED A HOLD HARMLESS
TO ENSURE THAT DISTRICTS AND
HAVE TIME TO PLAN AND TO KNOW
HOW MUCH FUNDING THEY WILL BE
GETTING AS A TRANSITION TO THE
NEW FUNDING FORMULA. AND WE HAVE
AN ON GOING.
HOLD HARMLESS AS WELL AS PART
OF THAT.
ABSOLUTELY THINKING ABOUT.
AT PROVIDING THE COLLEGES WITH
SAM AND STABILITY IN PLANNING
AND SO I THINK THOSE ARE ALL
THINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN THINKING
ABOUT IN TRAINING CORPORATE INTO
INTO OUR PROPOSAL.
I WOULD JUST AND AND I. RESPECT
YOUR YOUR PLOT POINT ABOUT US
NOT DOING ENOUGH TO TO WORK WITH
LEGISLATORS IF THERE'S WORK THAT
WE SHOULD BE DOING OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL MONTHS.
WE ARE HAPPY TO DO IT I DO ONE
IT JUST.
.
YOU KNOW MAYBE SUGGEST THAT I
DON'T THINK THIS IS THE THIS
HAVE BEEN.
CONSIDERED IN OUR SYSTEM IN THE
LEGISLATURE OVER THE PAST DECADE
BUT I THINK THIS IS A CONVERT
CONVERSATION THAT'S HAPPENED
BEFORE.
YOU KNOW THOSE PROPOSALS
HAVEN'T BEEN ENACTED WE THINK
IT'S.
THIS IS A MODEST STEP FORWARD
THAT BEGINS TO.
INCORPORATE SOME OF THESE
ADDITIONAL VALUES VALUES AROUND.
YOU KNOW BEGINNING TO CONSIDER
AS PART OF A FONT FUNDING
FORMULA STUDENT CHARACTERISTICS
THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT A. YOU KNOW
TO RECOGNIZE AND THEN.
THIS EMPHASIS ON PERFORMANCE
AND I WOULD SAY I THINK THE
TIMING IN MANY WAYS IS DRIVEN BY
OUR BOARDS.
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF THE VISION
FOR SUCCESS THAT WE NEED TO
BEGIN TO DO MORE BUT A PRETTY
FAST TIME FRAME THAT THE VISION
FOR SUCCESS SAYS THAT WE WILL
MEET THE GOALS BY TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. AND IF WE'RE GONNA.
YET ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS I THINK
WE FEEL PRETTY STRONGLY THAT.
THE WORK NEEDS TO BEGIN
IMMEDIATELY.
I I HEARD SAID THAT.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME THAT
THIS PROPOSAL HAS BEEN THAT.
BROUGHT UP AND THAT IT'S BEEN
BROUGHT UP IN THE LAST DECADE
BUT I I I WOULD REMIND THE
COMMITTEE THAT. THAT AS A SENIOR
MEMBER THERE'S NO ONE WHO'S BEEN
IN THIS LEGISLATURE LONGER THAN
I. A AND THAT'S FIVE YEARS SIX
YEARS RIGHT NOW. AND.
AND THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
WE'RE HEARING ABOUT IT AND
TALKING ABOUT IT I MEAN I DON'T
MEAN TO SUGGEST THIS SPECIFIC
PROPOSAL BUT I THINK THESE TYPES
OF CONCEPTS THINKING ABOUT
PERFORMANCE IN THE CONTEXT OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FINANCE.
THINKING ABOUT EQUITY IN THIS
CONTEXT I THINK THESE ARE.
ISSUES THAT CAME UP IN THE
STUDENT SUCCESS TASK FORCE ON
THESE ARE ISSUES THAT CAME UP IN
WORK LED BY OUR PARTNERS.
YOU KNOW THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY PREVIOUSLY
AND SO YOU WRITE. THIS PROPOSAL
IS CERTAINLY.
YOU KNOW SOMETHING THAT CAME
OUT IN JANUARY BUT I.
I DON'T THINK WE'VE.
WE'VE BEEN DELIBERATING ON
SIMILAR ISSUES.
FOR FIRST A NUMBER OF YEARS.
I I HAVE NO OTHER.
I DON'T THINK I DON'T HAVE ANY
OTHER RECOURSE THAN TO TO SAY
THAT I I I WOULD THINK THAT THE.
.
WE NEED TO SLOW THE PROCESS
DOWN.
IF I DON'T FEEL.
INCLUDED IN IN THE PROCESS I I
HAVE VERY LITTLE DOUBT THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF. FOLKS IN
THE.
IN THE COMMUNICABLE ITS
COMMUNITY THAT FEEL THE SAME
WAY.
AND I JUST DON'T THINK THE BEST
POLICY IS EVER MADE JUST RUSSIAN
IT THROUGH.
THANK YOU SOMEONE MEMBERS ONLY
MEMBER LIMON.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS I THINK FROM COLLEAGUES
IT THEY'VE BEEN PARTICULARLY
HELPFUL IN IN THINKING THROUGH
THE ISSUES. AND MY QUESTION IS
AND I THINK IT'S FOR YOU KNOW.
THAT THOSE OF YOU TO THINK ABOUT
AS I KEEP HEARING IN THE FUNDING
FORMULA.
I ALSO KEEP REFERENCING TO THE
EXPERIENCE I HAD AS A SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER WITHOUT LC FF AND
THEN WITH KELSEY FF.
AND THE REASON I BRING THAT UP
IS BECAUSE THAT THERE IS A LOT.
THE FEELINGS THAT ARE VERY
SIMILAR AROUND MOVING TO A LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
BUT I ASK MYSELF WHAT DO SUCCESS
LOOK LIKE UNDER THIS FUNDING
FORMULA IN THE EYES OF STUDENTS.
BUT I THINK FUND IT AYE I THINK
FUNDAMENTALLY IT IS.
IMPROVED DEGREE AND CERTIFICATE
ATTAINMENT IMPROVE TRANSFER OR.
IMPROVE COMPLETION OF CAREER
ORIENTED PROGRAMS.
PARTICULARLY AMONG STUDENTS TO.
WE SEE GAPS IN PERFORMANCE THAT
TODAY.
SO THOSE ARE A. I ACTUALLY THINK
THAT DOES SOUND LIKE GOALS THAT
YOU MAY ALL HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT LIKE WHAT IS GONNA
CHANGE IN THE LIFE OF A STUDENT.
ON EVERY DAY BASES A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
CAMPUS BY GOING TO THIS FOR
THIS FORMULA LIKE WHAT IT IS WAS
THEIR EXPERIENCE GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT.
ARE THEY GONNA HAVE MORE ACCESS
TO PROGRAMS LESS ACCESS. AND OR
LIMITED ACCESS BUT NOW MORE
FOCUSED AS OPPOSED TO MUCH
GENERAL ADVISING WHAT DOES THIS
REALLY LOOK LIKE. FROM A STUDENT
PERSPECTIVE.
AND I WOULD JUST ECHO SOME OF
THE COMMENTS THAT THE LA ALL
MADE THAT.
THERE IS THROUGH RESEARCH THAT
CORRELATES AT AN INCENTIVE SOME
FUNDING FORMULAS WITH BEHAVIORAL
CHANGES AT THE INSTITUTION.
THINGS LIKE REVAMPING STUDENT
ADVISING STREAMLINING
FINANCIALLY PROCESS THESE
INCREASING DATA TO INFORM
DECISIONS SO THERE IS RESEARCH
OUT THERE THAT'S SHOWS I'M VERY
REAL PRACTICES AND BEHAVIORS
THAT CHANGE WHEN THE FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES CHANGE.
RIGHT AND AND AGAIN THAT IS I
THINK A RESPONSE AND.
IT THAT THAT SOUNDS TO ME FROM
THE EYES OF AN ADMINISTRATOR
RATE SO WHEN I THINK OF THIS IS
SO INCREASE ACCESS TO FINANCIAL
AID SO THERE'S GONNA BE LESS
FINANCIAL AID LINES ARE NOT HAVE
TO WAIT IN LINE LONGER THE
PROCESS IS GOING TO GO FASTER
THEY'RE GONNA. GET AN EMERGENCY
LOAN LIKE WHAT DOES THIS LOOK
LIKE FOR STUDENTS THEY'RE GONNA
GET TO SEE AN ADVISER A
COUNSELOR SOONER. AND THEIR
CLASSES ARE GOING TO BE FULL AND
THEY'RE NOT GONNA HAVE TO WAIT
ANOTHER SEMESTER TO GET YOU KNOW
THE A GET THE CLASSES WHAT IS IT
LOOKS LIKE FOR STUDENTS.
YEAH THAT I THINK THERE ARE
SPECIFIC PRACTICES THAT WE'VE
WE'VE HEARD FROM LOCAL COLLEGES
LAKE I'M NOT STREAMLINING
FINANCIAL INVESTING IN SOFTWARE
TO STREAMLINE FINANCIAL APOSTASY
SO HE COULD AND HE GET OUT
THERE.
AND WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR A
STUDENT TO STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS SEES WHAT IS THAT MEAN
FOR THE STUDENTS STUDENT AS I
HAVE TO WAIT IN LINE THEY'RE
ABLE TO GET THEIR FINANCIAL AID
MUCH QUICKER SO THEY'RE ABLE TO
PLAN. AND.
PLAN FOR THE PROGRAMS.
BUT BY EMPRESS FOR SOME OF
FINANCE I WOULD ALSO ADD THE
WHAT IT MEANS FOR STUDENT IS NOW
THAT THAT STAFF IS NO LONGER
FOCUSED ON THE MANUAL PROCESSING
OF APPLICATIONS. GRADUALLY
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
THAT THE STUDENT WOULD HAVE. TO
HELP THEM FILL OUT THE THE FORMS
IF THEY'RE GETTING STUCK ON A
PARTICULAR YOU KNOW BOX IN THE
IMPACT OF WHAT THAT MEANS. SO
REALLY FROM A STUDENT THEY HAVE
MORE ACCESS TO THE TYPES OF HELP
THAT THEY WOULD NEED TO COMPLETE
THEIR APPLICATIONS. TO RECEIVE
FINANCIAL AID I THINK YOU WILL
SEE COLLEGES LOOK POURED SOME OF
THOSE ASPECTS I'M IF WE LOOK
PORT AB SEVEN OH FIVE. YOU KNOW
IT IT'S THOSE TYPE OF ASPECTS
WERE FROM A STUDENT NOW YOUR
HIGH SCHOOL GPA AND TRANSCRIPT
DATA MAY BE USED. TO HELP PLACE
TO IN COURSES SO THAT YOU CAN
BETTER OUT COMPLETE.
COLLEGE LEVEL MATH AND ENGLISH
COURSES IN A MORE TIMELY MANNER
WHICH ACTUALLY LEADS TO A MORE
TIMELY COMPLETION OF YOUR DEGREE
SO THOSE ARE REAL WORLD THINGS
THAT A STUDENT WOULD SEE.
WELL I GUESS YOU KNOW. SPEAKING
OF TIME TO DEGREE I MEAN THAT
MEANS A LOT FOR THOSE OF US THAT
WORKED ON TIME TO AGREE I JUST.
YET YOU KNOW IT'S A GOOD GOAL
AND I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW IT HELPS THE EVERYDAY
STUDENT BECAUSE THEY THINK THAT
THAT IS.
FOR ME ONE OF THE PIECES THAT'S
BEEN MISSING I HEAR A LOT OF THE
ULTIMATE GOALS IT HAS BUT I ALSO
THINK. THAT A LOT OF THE FUNDING
FORMULAS DATE THE PENDULUM DOES
SWING IT DOES GO FROM ONE STATE
TO ANOTHER WE BELIEVING
CATEGORICAL AS WERE VERY
FOCUSED.
AND THEN WE KIND OF MOVE BACK
AND WE DO MORE OF A BLOCK GRANT
OR SOME LC FF MODEL. AND I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT AS WE
MOVE IN ANY DIRECTION OUT WE
DON'T LOSE SIGHT THAT IF THE
STUDENTS NOT SEEN. THIS THAT
POSITIVE IMPACT I THINK IT IT IT
BECOMES A REAL CHALLENGE
I. AND.
YOU KNOW IT FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
THERE IS DEFINITELY AA THINK.
.
TO PROPOSALS THAT HAVE JET AND
GENERATED A LOT OF CONVERSATION
HOME AROUND THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THIS BEING ONE OF THEM.
AND THE PROPOSAL AND IN THE THE
COMMENTS AT LEAST FROM THE
DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT
GENERATE MORE QUESTIONS AND
CONCERNS AND I WONDER WHAT THAT.
YOU KNOW AND AND NOT NECESSARILY
STRICT OPPOSITION AS IS MORE OF
LIKE HERE'S.
BUDGET QUESTIONS TO ASK
HOW DO WE KNOW IT'S GONNA WORK.
AT THE HOLD HARMLESS AND IN THE
HOLD HARMLESS CAME FROM THE K.
TO TWELVE HEALTHY FF WORLD LIKE
WE ALL KNOW WHERE THAT CAME FROM
EIGHTEEN FROM A SPACE WHERE
THERE WERE SCHOOL DISTRICTS OVER
AND OVER COMING TO LEGISLATORS
AND SAY. WE ARE YOU KNOW NOT
BENEFITING FROM THIS.
AND WHERE THE LOSERS THE
WINNERS AND LOSERS DISCOURSE
CAME FROM THAT AND. AND THOSE
CONCERNS BY I THINK WE HAVE WAYS
TO GO TO TRY TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
TO BRING FOLKS ON BOARD I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE STEPS ARE I FEEL
LIKE I ACTUALLY THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES I THINK HAVE BEEN
DOING.
AN EXCELLENT JOB AND HOLDING
REGIONAL MEETINGS WAY IF
EDUCATORS AND STAKEHOLDERS BUT
IT SEEMS THAT THOSE HAVE BEEN
HELPFUL BUT THEY HAVEN'T MET.
AND THE ULTIMATE GOAL OF REALLY
BRINGING EVERYBODY EDUCATORS
INCLUDED ONBOARD.
TO SAY HEY I THINK WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS.
AND IN THE END FOR ME IF I AM.
IF THE STUDENT IS GOING TO SEE
KIND OF EVERY DAY EXPERIENCE OR.
THAT THE STATUS QUO IN SOME WAY.
I WORRY THAT WE HAVEN'T PUT
THAT STEPS IN THE STRUCTURE THE
PATHWAY THERE TO GET TO THESE
REALLY GOOD GOALS THAT I CAN
AGREE WITH ALL THOSE GOAL YOU'VE
MENTIONED NOT ONE GOAL THAT I
DISAGREE WITH. THAT I THINK
WOULD BE BAD FOR STUDENTS.
BUT I THINK THAT IF THE
PATHWAYS NOT CREATED. TO GET
BOTH EDUCATORS AND STUDENTS
THERE. IT'S REALLY HARD TO GET
TO THE SCHOOLS.
SO AND YOU KNOW I A HERE THE
PROPOSAL'S I HEAR THE COMMENTS
GENERATED BY COLLEAGUES AND I
FIND THEM HELPFUL AND.
YOU KNOW.
I'M STILL KIND OF THINKING OF
WHAT SPACE WHAT'S MISSING TO GET
US THERE A IS IT TIME THAT'S
MISSING IS IT MORE STAKEHOLDER
INVOLVEMENT AND.
I YOU KNOW I I MET LITTLE BIT AT
A LOSS I DON'T KNOW THAT I HAVE
A SOLUTION TO OFFER.
AS MUCH AS I'M JUST TRYING TO
PROVIDE A PERSPECTIVE OF HAVING
HAD THIS CONVERSATION FOR
SEVERAL MONTHS NOW UNDER STILL
LITTLE BIT OF A GAP THAT'S
THERE.
DON'T THINK YOU FOR YOUR.
ANSWERS.
THANK YOU MISTER MARTZ RICHIE.
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
SO.
.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YOU
STARTED OFF YOUR PRESENTATION BY
TALKING ABOUT HOW.
THE CURRENT SYSTEM PRIORITIZES
ENROLLMENT NOT STUDENT SUCCESS.
AND SO.
FROM THAT.
PERSPECTIVE IF YOU'RE IF THE
PROPOSED.
CHANGE IN THE FUNDING FORMULA IS
TO.
PRIORITIZE STUDENT SUCCESS I
WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU A LETTER
THAT I RECEIVED FROM.
WHAT I BELIEVE IS A SUCCESSFUL
COMMUNICABLE H. IN MY DISTRICT
EL CAMINO COLLEGE?
I AM LOOKING AT A LETTER FROM
THE PRESIDENT OF EL CAMINO.
COMMITTEE COLLEGE HERE.
AND AND SHE'S SHE'S SITES HOW.
.
WHILE THE NEW FORMULA IS
OSTENSIBLY DESIGNED TO IMPROVE
DECLINE DEGREE COMPLETION AND
OTHER OUTCOMES.
IT ACTUALLY THREATENS TO CUT
FUNDING FOR WELL PERFORMING
COLLEGES LIKE EL CAMINO COLLEGE.
WHERE OVER SEVENTY PERCENT OF
OUR COLLEGE PREPARES STUDENTS
COMPLETE A DEGREE OR
CERTIFICATE?
OR ARE READY TO TRANSFER TO A
FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITY.
WHEN THEY FINISH THEIR STUDIES
HERE.
EL CAMINO RANKS THIRD IN THE
STATE FOR TRANSFERS TO CSU. AND
ARE CONSISTENTLY IN THE TOP TEN
IN THE STATE FOR TRANSFERS TO
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM.
SO.
YEAH I EL COMINO IS ONE OF THE
SCHOOLS THAT.
ACCORDING TO THE LATEST
PROJECTIONS ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
CUT.
BY THIS NEW FUNDING FORMULA.
WITHOUT THE HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISION AND
BUT I AM STILL ARE CONFUSED AS
TO HOW THE HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISION WORKS BECAUSE.
WHAT SHE TOLD ME?
IS THAT THE HOLD HARMLESS WHO
BATES BASICALLY ONLY PROTECT
THEM FOR ONE YEAR.
.
AND AND SO AND THE MOST POWERFUL
STATEMENT AND IN THIS LETTER.
THAT I FIND HERE IS THAT IF THE
FUNDING FORMULA GOES FORWARD AS
ORIGINALLY DEFINED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WITHOUT
THE BENEFIT OF THE EXPERIENCE.
PERSPECTIVE AND ANALYSIS OF THE
C. E. O.'S AND CB OWES OF OUR
COMMUNICATIVE IS. THIS MAY PROVE
TO BE THE WORST EXPERIMENT AND
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
CALIFORNIA HAS EVER SEEN.
SO.
THIS LETTER HERE.
COMING FROM. YOU KNOW SOMEONE
WHO IS IN CHARGE OF RUNNING ONE
OF OUR MOST SUCCESSFUL COMMITTEE
COLLEGES.
YOU KNOW.
RACES.
SERIOUS DOUBT IN MY MIND AS TO.
HOW MUCH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS CONSULTED WITH OUR
COMMUNICATIVE LEADERS WHO HAVE
BEEN PRODUCING THE SUCCESSFUL
RESULTS?
I SEE ME LIKE A RESPONSE TO
THAT.
IF YOU LIKE MAYBE THERE ARE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
YEAH I'VE I THINK ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES WE'VE FACED.
IN THIS PROCESS IS THERE IS A
FISCAL YEAR STARTING.
AND THERE'S STILL A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY AND I THINK THE
UNCERTAINTY.
IS MAKING OF FOLKS YOU KNOW.
ANXIOUS IS PROBABLY A VERY.
MILDLY TO PUT IT I THINK
HOPEFULLY WE CAN DESIGN IN OUR
INTENT WHAT WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
CEOS THAT WE'VE CONSULTED WITH
PICK AND.
CHANCELLOR OAKLEY ASKED A GROUP
OF CIOS TO THINK THROUGH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
HEAT WE'VE RELIED ON THE ADVICE
ADVISORY WORK GROUP ON FISCAL
AFFAIRS WHICH IS A GROUP OF CBO
SO WE HAVE CONSULTED WITH THEM I
THINK THERE IS A STRONG
RECOMMENDATION FROM BOTH OF
THOSE GROUPS THAT.
WE NEED A HOLD HARMLESS THAT IS.
YOU KNOW TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL A DISTRICT WOULD GET NO
LESS THAN A GETS IN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN AND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. AND THEN BEGINNING IN
NINETEEN TWENTY OF A DISTRICT
WOULD GET NO LESS ON A PER
STUDENT BASIS I THINK WHAT THE
LETTER SUGGESTS IS THAT.
DISTRICTS ARE SEEKING A OF A
LONGER PERIOD WHERE THEY ARE
HELD AT NO LESS THAN THE
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN LEVELS AND I
THINK FOR MANY DISTRICTS.
THEY WOULD LIKE NO LESS THAN
THE SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN LEVELS
ADJUSTED FOR THE COST OF LIVING.
.
HE KNOWS THE. YEAH.
WE HEAR THAT AND I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE TAKING IT
INTO VERY STRONG CONSIDERATION
AS WE THINK ABOUT
RECOMMENDATIONS A TO MAKE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I THINK
THE CHALLENGES ONE THAT WAS.
PRODUCT BY THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THAT BE. UP THE
LONGER YOU.
HOLD DISTRICTS HARMLESS AND THE
MORE MONEY WE SPEND FOR THOSE
PROVISIONS.
.
THAT'S LESS MONEY THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO USE TO CREATE THE TYPES
OF INCENTIVES WE WANT TO CREATE
SO I THINK THAT'S THE BALANCE
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO STRIKE NAM. BUT I I HOPE AND
I I THINK THE YOU KNOW. THE
MESSAGE WE WOULD GIVE IS THAT WE
HAVE HEARD A LOT OF THESE
CONCERNS LOUD AND CLEAR WE ARE.
TRYING TO BE RESPONSIVE TO THAT
RECOGNIZING THAT WE HAVE A GOAL
OF TRYING TO. BUY IMPLEMENT A
FORMULA THAT.
ACHIEVES THE KINDS OF
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR.
FOR UNDERSERVED STUDENTS AND
THAT AND ENCOURAGES THE TYPES OF
INCIDENTS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT.
WELL.
AND I WOULD JUST ADD THAT THAT
WE'VE BEEN ENGAGED IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE CBO IS IN
THE SEALS AND.
VARIOUS DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS
AND WE ARE TAKING THEIR
FEEDBACK.
CONSIDERATION.
ALRIGHT WELL I I I DON'T KNOW IF
A.
THEM PRESIDENT OF EL CAMINO
COLLEGE WAS NOT PART OF.
THESE GROUPS AND THAT.
OF THESE CEOS EVEN.
CONSULTING WITH BETTER.
YEAH I.
I FIND MYSELF AGREEING WITH THE
ARE ARE CHAIR OF OUR.
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS THE RUSH HERE.
I MEAN IF THERE ARE. IF THE CEO
OF ONE OF THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
COMMITTEE COLLEGES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IS SAYING. YOU
KNOW THAT THEY ARE NOT BEING
ADEQUATELY CONSULTED.
I HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THAT AND.
AS LONG AS I'M HEARING.
THINGS LIKE THIS I CANNOT
SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S.
FUNDING FORMULA.
THANK YOU BUT. I THINK WHAT SEN.
WHAT WE'D LIKE TO FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF ICQ COLLEGES IS
TO?
IS TO MOVE.
HERE AS WE TALK ABOUT THE TWO
HEARINGS NOW. HERE FROM THAT THE
PUBLIC NOT TO SET THIS.
I HEARING BUT ACROSS CALIFORNIA
POTENTIALLY TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION DURING THE MARY
VISION AND AND WILL LOOK AT THAT
AND WE MAY COME UP WITH THEIR
OWN. CULTURE TO PLAN HER NEXT
THE PLAN ALTOGETHER WHAT HAVE
YOU SO WEAK WE RESERVE THAT
RIGHT CERTAINLY.
BUT I THINK TO IT I JUST WANT
TO. REITERATE THAT.
.
THAT THE GOAL OF THE LCF THAT.
WHEN WE STARTED THIS THING QUE
TWELVE WAS A WORTHY ONE AND
THAT'S WHY I THINK WE.
WE'VE WE LIKED HOW IT'S BEEN
ROLLED OUT THE K. TWELVE LEVEL
TO SOME EXTENT WAS STILL A LONG
WAYS TO GO AS FAR AS JUST.
FRANKLY RESOURCES.
AND THAT'S WHY WE STARTED THIS
DISCUSSION.
LAST YEAR BUT.
WHICH ONE TO MAKE SURE HOW THIS
IS IMPLEMENTED THAT WERE SERVING
THE STUDENTS WHO THE
COMMUNICATIVE TARGET OTHER.
THEY TIMES.
.
LOW INCOME FIRST IN THEIR FAMILY
TO GO TO COLLEGE AND WE WE
WOULDN'T WANT.
IT TO TO TO GO AWAY FROM WHAT
THAT WE'VE BEEN ALL ABOUT FOR
THE LAST.
HUNDRED YEARS OR SO IN
CALIFORNIA SERVING NEARLY TWO
MILLION COMMITTEE CALLED STATE
ITSELF.
SO WITH THAT.
FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS WILL.
OPEN IT UP TO.
PUBLIC COMMENTS NOW STAY WITH
HER.
I ASK I ASK THE PUBLIC TO PLEASE
KEEP YOUR. COMMENTS TO ONE
MINUTE OR LESS THANK YOU. ONE
MINUTE JIM MILLER PRESIDENT OF
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE COUNCIL
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS.
I'M SOME VERY QUICK POINTS IN
LESS THAN ONE MINUTE NUMBER ONE
IF WE'RE GONNA PUT A MODEL IN
PLACE THAT REWARDS STUDENT
OUTCOMES IT WE'RE GONNA BECOME
NOTHING MORE THAN DIPLOMA MILLS.
IF AYE AS PRESIDENT OF OUR UNION
EVERYONE WHO GIVES MORES GETS A
TEN PERCENT INCREASE PEOPLE
GIVEN MORES. RIGHTS OF THIS IS
THAT THEY HAVE ANYTHING THAT
STUDENT. PERFORMANCE BASED IS
GONNA BE A DISINCENTIVE FOR US
TO REALLY HAVE QUALITY PROGRAMS.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES SECONDLY
TO ECHO AND MR MEDINA MISTER
MARSTERS HIS COMMENTS.
THERE HASN'T BEEN ENOUGH TIME TO
STUDY THIS IS THIS IS BEN RUSHD
IF ANYONE WERE TO SAVE IT TO ANY
REASONABLE PERSON WE'RE GONNA
OVERHAUL THE COME. WE'RE GOING
TO COMPLETELY OVERHAUL THE
FUNDING FORMULA FOR THE LARGEST
INSTITUTION OF HIGHER EDUCATION
IN THE UNITED STATES WITH VERY
LITTLE SHOULD STAKEHOLDER INPUT.
AND WE'RE GONNA DO IT IN A FEW
MONTHS TIME PEOPLE THINK YOU
WOULD BE CRAZY TO DO THAT SO WE
NEED FAR MORE TIME TO STUDY THIS
IN DETAIL BECAUSE THERE ARE SO
MANY. UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN CONSIDERED
YET WITH THIS AND LASTLY IT WAS
MENTIONED ABOUT THE HOLD
HARMLESS WHICH IS BASICALLY GIVE
DISTRICT THEIR BUDGETS. THAT
THEY HAVE THIS YEAR AND KEEP
THEM AT THAT LEVEL.
THAT'S VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT WE
DO WITH THE BASIC EIGHT
DISTRICTS NOW THOUGH THE
DISTRICTS THAT DON'T RELY ON
STATE APPORTIONMENT THE FUNCTION
WHY NOT ADOPT THAT FUNDING MODEL
FOR ALL COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHY
NOT JUST SAY TO EVERYBODY.
HERE'S YOUR BUDGET YOU KNOW WHAT
TO DO WITH IT DO THE BEST THING
YOU CAN TO SERVE STUDENTS WHICH
IS WHAT WE DO WITH TEN PERCENT
OF THE DISTRICTS WHY CAN'T THAT
BE GOOD ENOUGH FOR THE OTHER
NINETY PERCENT OF THE DISTRICTS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MUCH DIMMER COMING
FROM A PRESENT LUSTROUS COLLEGE
FEDERATION TEACHERS ALSO A VICE
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION DISHES. VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE FACT THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA CAN BE
COLLEGES.
I JUST WANNA SAY IT JUST A
COUPLE THINGS THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU THE VALUE.
DEGREES AND CERTIFICATES OVER
THE LEARNING DEVELOPMENT
MATURITY OF YOUR STUDENTS AND
THAT THEY'RE BETTER PREPARED IT
LIKE IT'S THAT PART THEY DON'T
CARE ABOUT THEY DON'T TALK ABOUT
IT. THAT'S WHAT WE S. FACTLY
CARE ABOUT.
YEAH SO THAT'S MORE IMPORTANT TO
ME THE OTHER PART OF IT IS THAT
YOU KNOW OF THE CEO GROUP HAS
JUST. CONCLUDED THEIR WORK JUST
ABOUT A WEEK OR TWO AGO ON THIS
FUNDING FORMULA COURTS WITHIN
MIT THIS IS A BROAD OUTLINE THEY
HAVE NOT RUN ONE SIMULATION AND
HOW THIS WOULD AFFECT. THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO.
IF YOUR GONNA GO AHEAD AND
APPROVE SOMETHING LIKE THIS IN
WHICH NO SIMULATIONS HAVE BEEN
DONE THAT THIS IS GOD THIS IS
JUST CRAZY. OKAY.
ABSOLUTELY THE OTHER THING I DO
WANT TO SAY NO ONE MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS THIS IS
THAT WITHIN THE CURRENT FUNDING
FORMULA WHICH WE HAVE A GROWTH
MULLIN WHICH OCCURRED. SINCE I
SPS THREE SIXTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND SIX.
OKAY WE DO IT WITH THERE IS A
CONCERN THAT MORE MONEY NEEDS TO
GO TO THE TO THOSE DISTRICTS
THAT ARE SERVING ON A. A VERY
NEEDY STUDENTS SO IN THE AYE
FORMULA WE ALREADY HAVE OF OF A
A FACTOR THAT INVOLVES
UNEMPLOYMENT.
I'M POVERTY. AND THERE'S ANOTHER
ONE THAT ALSO IN YOUR DISTRICT
THE NUMBER OF DEGREE.
GRADUATE DEGREES THERE IN YOUR
DISTRICT SO IF YOU'RE IN A
DISTRICT THAT HOUSED LA LOT OF
NON DEGREE EARNERS YOU'RE GOING
TO GET MORE MONEY.
THE OTHER ONE IS GOING TO BE.
ALSO HOW MANY PELL GRANTS THAT
ARE BEING SERVED IN THE DISTRICT
SO THESE ARE ALREADY FACTORS ARE
ALREADY IN THE BUDGET FORMULA
RIGHT NOW. AND SO IS NOT AS IF
WE DON'T CARE ABOUT THOSE THOSE
ISSUES AND THINGS IT'S BEEN IN
PLACE FOR OVER TEN YEARS
ALREADY.
SO ALL IF IF WE NEED TO ADJUST
THAT MAKES SOME SENSE SMALL
ADJUSTMENTS I'M FINE WITH THAT.
BUT. NO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS THESE
FACTORS ARE ALREADY INCLUDED IN
THE CURRENT BUDGET POINT. THANK
YOU.
GOOD EVENING I'M JOHN STANCE
BECAUSE I'M THE PRESIDENT ELECT
OF THE ACADEMIC SENATE FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES I
REPRESENT. ALL FIFTY THOUSAND
FACULTY IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM. AND AYE ACADEMIC
MATTERS.
I I'M HERE TODAY TO TELL YOU WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT A DISCUSSION OF
THE FUNDING FORMULA IS WORTHY OF
CONSIDERATION. WE HAVE ASKED TO
PARTICIPATE IN SOME OF THESE
REAP WORK GROUPS THAT ARE
MEETING TO DO THAT AND WE WERE
ON.
WE WERE DENIED ACCESS TO THOSE
WORK GROUPS AND SO BEING ABLE
TO.
I HAVE ACCESS TO SOME OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AND DIALOGUE MAY
SHAPE. I'M OUTCOME OF WHAT YOU
WOULD SEE HERE.
.
WE ARE INTERESTED IN HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT FUNDING BUT
WE ARE OPPOSED TO ANY FUNDING
FORMULA THAT HAS.
PERFORMANCE BASED FUNDING FOR
SEVERAL REASONS ONE OF THEM IS
THAT THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT
IT MOVES THE NEEDLE ON OVERALL
OUTCOMES WHICH SOUNDS LIKE THAT
IS THE GOAL. ON THAT'S
EVERYONE'S GOAL.
.
THE SECOND PROBLEM WITH THE
PERFORMANCE SPACE PIECE IS THAT
I HAVE.
I THINK IT'S AN INHERENTLY
FLAWED IDEA TO THINK. THAT IF WE
CHANGE HOW WE FIND THE COLLEGE
ON OUTCOMES THAT IT WILL CHANGE
THE THE.
ACTUAL PERFORMANCE OF THE
COLLEGES.
BECAUSE FACULTY ARE DEDICATED TO
THE OUTCOMES OF THEIR STUDENTS.
WE.
ARE COMMITTED TO THE SOCIAL
JUSTICE MISSION OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AS AGENTS FOR ECONOMIC MOBILITY
IN THE STATE.
SOME OF THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT BY FUNDING
OUTCOMES INCLUDE. THE.
.
DISENFRANCHISEMENT FURTHER
DISENFRANCHISEMENT OF
POPULATIONS WE ARE EXPLICITLY
TRYING TO REACH.
IN TERMS OF FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENTS
AND.
ESPECIALLY OUR STUDENTS OF
COLOR AND RETURNING STUDENTS.
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE TODAY A ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LIMON YOU ASKED SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW THIS WOULD
IMPACT STUDENTS.
HERE'S SOME WAYS THAT WOULD
WE CAN ONLY FIND A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF CLASSES IN THE
SCHEDULE. AND I KNOW THAT MY.
STUDENTS
WHO ARE RETURNING STUDENTS TO
HAVE STUDENTS IN PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND NEED TO LIMIT THE
AMOUNT OF TIME THEY SPEND ON
CAMPUS.
WOULD BENEFIT FROM THE
SCHEDULING A CLASS ON FRIDAYS.
FROM TEN TO THREE. SO THAT THEY
CAN GET THEIR STUDENTS TO SCHOOL
THEY CAN COME TO THE CLASS AND
THEN THEY CAN LEAVE. I ALSO KNOW
THAT THE SUCCESS RATE IN THAT
CLASS IS LOWER. THAN STUDENTS
WERE ABLE TO COME.
MONDAY THROUGH THURSDAY AT TEN
O'CLOCK.
THANK YOU WHO ARE USUALLY
YOUNGER.
WHICH ONE OF MY GOING TO
SCHEDULE.
TO FIND WHEN THAT FUNDING
FORMULA IS PRESSURING ME TO
CONSIDER IT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS ANNA HOT AND I TEACH
ENGLISH AT AMERICAN RIVER
COLLEGE I AM ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE LOS. RIOS CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS
WELL I WELCOME ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. I HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS WHAT COMPONENT NUMBER
THREE.
THIS COMPONENT KNOWN AS A
STUDENT SUCCESS INCENTIVE GRANT
SIMPLY CREATES A CHILLING
EFFECTS.
AND POSES A THREAT TO MY
PROFESSION.
GIVING ALL DISTRICTS IN
INCENTIVE TO ABORT DEGREES AND
CERTIFICATES WILL MAKE THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM INTO
DIPLOMA MILL.
THEREFORE OUR SEE IF T. OPPOSES
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR ANY
TYPE OF PERFORMANCE SPACE
FUNDING METHODOLOGY.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
MANNER.
THANK YOU.
HONORABLE REPRESENTATIVES.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK REGARDING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED FUNDING MODEL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
I AM PRESIDENT OF SHOULD BOW
COLLEGE ON SUSAN SPERLING. WHICH
SERVES FIFTEEN THOUSAND STUDENTS
AND ONE OF THE MOST.
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES IN THE
NATION.
I IT'S ON THE BASIS OF LONG
FAMILIARITY WITH OUR STUDENTS
I'VE BEEN AT THE COLLEGE FOR
THIRTY YEARS ALTHOUGH NOT ALL
THIRTY OF THOSE YEARS AS COLLEGE
PRESIDENT MOST OF THEM AS A
TEACHER. IN OUR CLASSROOMS.
I FEEL THAT I AM. PRETTY DEEPLY
FAMILIAR WITH THE NEEDS AND
SUCCESSES OF OUR STUDENTS.
AND I SHARE.
BOB THE DEEP CONCERN ABOUT SOME
OF THE UNINTENDED IMPACTS OF THE
PROPOSED NEW FUNDING MODEL. THAT
COLLEAGUES FROM THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HAVE SPOKEN TO YOU
ABOUT AND THAT SOME OF OF THE
HONORABLE REPRESENTATIVES HERE
HAVE HAVE SPOKEN TO.
SHOULD BOW WE FULLY EMBRACE THE
VISION FOR SUCCESS.
AW AND SHOULD BOW IS ACTUALLY
RECOGNIZE LEADER. IN GUIDED
PATHWAYS AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT ARM FOR INSTANCE WE
ARE THE CRADLE AND BIRTHPLACE
OF.
SOME FAMOUS GUIDED PATHWAYS THE
POINT THEY PROGRAM.
DIRAJA MOSHE PROGRAM STRIVING
BLACK BROTHERS THESE ARE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE NOW NOT JUST
STATEWIDE BUT NATIONWIDE.
LIKE MANY LEADERS ACROSS THE
SYSTEM I ALSO KNOW THAT WE NEED
CHANGE OUR IN THE FUNDING
FORMULA NOT NO QUESTION ABOUT
THAT.
THE FUNDING MODEL YOU'RE
CURRENTLY CONSIDERING. RUSHES
TOWARDS A WORTHY GOAL WITHOUT
FULL ASSESSMENT.
OF POTENTIALLY GRAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT THREATEN TO
DAMAGE OUR COLLECTIVE GOALS.
WE ALL AGREE ON THE GOALS.
FOR EXAMPLE.
A PROPOSED MAC METRIC
FOR THE NEW FUNDING MODEL IS
GRADUATION WITHIN.
TWO OR THREE YEARS THREE YEARS.
MANY SHABBOS STUDENTS COM IN
FACT THE VAST MAJORITY OF
SHABBOS STUDENTS COME FROM FIRST
GENERATION. IMMIGRANT FAMILIES
FOR WHOM ENGLISH IS THEIR SECOND
LANGUAGE.
THEY NEED BASIC SKILLS CLASSES
THAT ENABLE THEM TO SUCCEED IN
COLLEGE.
IN ADDITION TO THEIR ROLES AS
STUDENTS THEY SERVICE
TRANSLATORS FOR FAMILY MEMBERS
WORKERS WHO SUPPORT.
A FAMILY INCOME IS VITAL AND
PINCH HITTERS FOR FAMILY
TRANSPORT AND CHILD AND ELDER
CARE.
EVEN WITH FINANCIAL INCENTIVES
TO ATTEND FULL TIME THESE
STUDENTS MAY ONLY BE ABLE TO
TAKE.
TWO CLASSES A SEMESTER THAT IS
THE SOCIAL SOCIO ECONOMIC
REALITY.
OF SIXTY SEVENTY BEYOND PERCENT
OF OUR STUDENTS LIVES SNAPPED AS
HE WRAPPED UP PRESIDENT IF
TRIPLE TIME OKAY.
.
SO.
WE STAND TO LOSE IN MY DISTRICT.
CONSIDERABLE FUNDING DESPITE THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE VERY VERY.
STRONG METRICS FOR STUDENT
SUCCESS AND I'M CONCERNED
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE
DISENFRANCHISEMENT OF THE
STUDENT I JUST MENTIONED THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU PRESIDENT.
GOOD EVENING I'M JIM REMAIN WITH
THE ACADEMIC SENATE AND I AM
TREASURER ELECT.
SO I'M GONNA TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT GUIDED PATHWAYS SO FIRST
OF ALL THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SPENDING YOUR LATE AFTERNOON
EARLY EVENING AND WITH YOUR
THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS.
THE GUIDED PATHWAYS PLANS HAVE
JUST BEEN SUBMITTED BY THE
COLLEGES BY THE HUNDRED FOURTEEN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THEY WERE DUE
ON MARCH THIRTIETH.
A GUIDED PATHWAYS ARE IN THE
VERY BEGINNING OF STAGES AND MAY
TAKE A MINIMUM OF FIVE YEARS IN
AS MANY AS TEN YEARS TO BE FULLY
IMPLEMENTED AT OUR HUNDRED
FOURTEEN COLLEGES.
SO I DON'T SEE HOW OUTCOMES
BASED FUNDING IS SUPPORTED BY
GUIDED PATHWAYS AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE NO DATA SUPPORTING THIS.
FURTHERMORE WE HAVE EVIDENCE
THAT OUTCOMES BASED FUNDING DOES
NOT INCREASED DEGREE AND
CERTIFICATE ATTAINMENT.
YES THE CURRENT MODEL ISN'T
WORKING BUT THERE IS NO EVIDENCE
THAT THIS WILL EITHER.
BUT MORE FULL TIME TEACHERS DOES
WORK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS YOU TODAY HAVE UP MY
NAME IS DIANE BRADY ON THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES AT LOS PROCEEDS COLLEGE
IN EAST BAY. UP I ALSO WANT TO
EXPRESS MY CONCERN ABOUT THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF THE
FUNDING FORMULA AS IT'S
CURRENTLY PROPOSED.
SOME SIMULATIONS REVEAL THAT
MORE THAN HALF OF ALL THE
COLLEGES STATEWIDE WOULD
EXPERIENCE A CUT IN THEIR
FUNDING. IN MANY CASES THE CUP
WOULD BE MORE SEVERE THAN WHAT
THE COLLEGES EXPERIENCE DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION A FEW YEARS
AGO.
IN ADDITION I WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE THE POINT THAT THE.
THE ASSERTION THAT THE COLLEGE
BUDGETS WOULD BE HELD HARMLESS.
IS MISLEADING IN THAT EVEN CALL
IT WOULD NOT BE GIVEN TO THOSE
COLLEGES WE WOULD BE HELD
HARMLESS AT THE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN RATE WHILE COSTS ARE
RISING FOR. UTILITIES AND
RETIREMENT AND OTHER THINGS WE
WOULD RECEIVE CALL A AND THAT
WAS ESSENTIALLY A PAY CUT.
OF AND EVEN WORSE THE FORMULA
FAILS TO HELP THE STUDENTS WHO
NEED US THE MOST IN THE SENSE
THAT THOSE WHO ARE ATTENDING
PART TIME. WE HAVE MORE THAN
SIXTY PERCENT OF OUR STUDENTS
ARE ATTENDING PART TIME. OR THEY
ON SUCCESSFUL IF THEY DON'T
REACH THEIR GOALS IN TWO OR
THREE YEARS BECAUSE IT TAKES
THEM LONGER MORE THAN SIXTY
PERCENT OF OUR STUDENTS HAVE TO
WORK MORE THAN TWENTY HOURS A
WEEK. UP AND I WOULDN'T CALL
THOSE STUDENTS UNSUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE THEY DON'T GET OUT IN
TWO OR THREE YEARS.
THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE THAT WAS
IN THE STUDENT THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS.
IT SAID GOAL SHOULD BE USED TO
MOTIVATE AND PROVIDE DIRECTION
NOT PUNISH.
THIS FORMULA'S IT'S WRITTEN
RIGHT NOW IS SEVERELY PUNITIVE.
I WOULD URGE THAT YOU PLEASE
TAKE THE TIME TO STUDY IT
LONGER.
AND MAKE SURE THAT THE FUNDING
FORMULA THAT WE DO COME UP.
MEETS THE INTENT THERE IS A
LAUDABLE INTENT BUT.
STILL MAINTAINS.
STABLE AND PREDICTABLE FUNDING
WITHOUT SIGNIFICANTLY HARMING
MANY OF THE DISTRICTS THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING JENNIFER BAKER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION.
WE UNDERSTAND THE GOLD THAT.
THE GOVERNOR'S TRYING TO
ACHIEVE AND WE THINK IT'S A LOT
OF LOCAL HERE TO TRY TO HAVE A
STABLE FORMULA PARTICULARLY
THROUGH TOUGH ECONOMIC TIMES.
THEIR QUESTION THAT WE WOULD
ASK REGARDING THE FIRST FIFTY
PERCENT.
IS IS THAT ENOUGH BASED ON THE
EXPERIENCES THAT WE'VE HAD ON
THE K. TWELVE SIDE WE REALIZED
INITIALLY WHEN THE LC FF WAS
CREATED. THE THOUGHT WAS THAT
WOULD BE ENOUGH TO CARRY THE
LONG TERM SYSTEMIC COST THAT THE
SYSTEM NEEDED IN AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW TO OTHER CONVERSATIONS WERE
FINDING OUT NOW THAT WE HAVE TO
DO SOME WHATEVER REVENGE. SO THE
QUESTION WE WE'D LIKE TO POSE
FOR THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SIDE.
IS FIFTY PERCENT GOING TO BE OUT
NOW FOR THE LONG TERM SYSTEMIC
IMPACTS IN COST INCREASES THAT
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE GOING
TO HAVE OVER THE YEARS WE THINK
IT WOULD BE A VERY THOUGHTFUL
FISCAL PROCESS TO ANALYZE THAT
TO MAKE SURE THAT BASE NUMBER IS
GOING TO BE. ENOUGH.
WE AGREE WITH MANY OF THE
CONCERNS SET UP A REYES
REGARDING.
DUH HOLD HARMLESS PROVISION FOR
ONE YEAR WE WOULD ASK IS THAT
ENOUGH.
AND WOOD OF THE IN THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES FOR THE
WINNERS AND LOSERS BECAUSE WE'VE
SEEN SIMILAR.
CONSEQUENCES ON THE KEY TWELVE
SITE FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE LC FF WE DO UNDERSTAND THE
INITIAL STUDENT.
GRANT TO HELP STUDENTS IN NEED
WE THINK THAT THERE WERE SOME
VERY VERY REFLECTIVE COMMENTS
FROM THE ALLEY YELLOW THAT WE'D
URGE YOU TO CHEW ON WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE OTHER TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT GRANT.
IF THE GOAL IS STUDENT SUCCESS.
WE CONCUR WITH MANY OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE BY PRE
SPEAKERS ON TRYING TO UTILIZE
METRICS THAT ENSURE STUDENT
SUCCESS SAID HE'S FULL TIME
FACULTY AND ACCESS FOR STUDENTS.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS LA HABILIDAD I
REPRESENT A NEXT GEN CALIFORNIA
NEXT GEN PRIORITIZES ACCESS TO
QUALITY EDUCATION AND TIME TO
COMPLETION AND HOUSE
WE CONTINUE THESE CONVERSATIONS
I NEXT AND REALLY WANTS TO
ENSURE THAT. DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS ARE REALLY PRIORITIZE
AMBIENCE OR THINK YOU.
I CHAIR MCCARTY CHAIR MEDINA
MEMBERS LYRICALLY ZERO WITH
THEIR COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEAGUE
WE REPRESENT ALL SEVENTY TWO
DISTRICTS IN HONOR AND FOURTEEN
COLLEGES. AND WE ALSO HAD I HAD
THE JOB.
TO HELP SUPPORT THE THE CEO
WORK GROUP THAT WAS TASKED
SURVEYED THE GOOD THING IS I'M
NOT GONNA TALK VERY LONG
BECAUSE.
YOU SHOULD HAVE ON YOUR DESK OUR
REPORT.
THAT ARE CONSTITUTES THIRD OF
RECOMMENDATIONS AND ACTUALLY
DEAN THIS CAME OUT JUST THIS
PAST MONDAY I JUST A COUPLE
THINGS I WOULD HIGHLIGHT IN AND.
SINCE THIS JUST CAME OUT MONDAY
THERE'S A DESIRE TO HAVE
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS BUT.
I THINK WHAT YOU'RE HEARING A
LOT ABOUT IS INSTITUTIONAL
CAPACITY SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMO
AND YOU ASKED THE KEY QUESTION
WHICH I'M NOT TO BE ABLE TO
ANSWER. BUT ABSENT INSTITUTIONAL
CAPACITY
WE ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
SERVE I ESPECIALLY THOSE
TRADITIONALLY UNDER REPRESENTED
AND MOST UNDERSERVED STUDENTS SO
IN THE RECOMMENDATIONS BY THE
CEO WORK GROUP. THERE IS.
A STRONG RECOMMENDATION FOR
BASS ALLOCATION RESOURCE AND
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY NOT
JUST FOR A NEW FUNDING FORMULA
ALTHOUGH IT'S CRITICAL FOR
PACKAGES SO THAT WE CAN. I DO
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO EQUITY
MINDED APPROACH TO TO FUNDING.
AND ALSO YOU'LL SEE IN THE IN
THE REPORT THAT THERE IS A PHASE
AND THAT'S RECOMMENDED IN THIS
PROCESS SO THANK YOU. SO MISTER
GLAZE YES IF YOU COULDN'T MAYBE
HANG OUT THERE BECAUSE I THINK
YOU YOU ARE.
KEY QUESTION IS THAT.
WE WE HEARD IN THE LETTER FROM
EL CAMINO RECEIVED A PHONE CALL
FROM TO DISTRICTS OUTSIDE OF MY
DISTRICT WE HEARD FROM THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD BOW AND.
AND YOU REPRESENT HUNDRED
FOURTEEN.
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN WHAT'S UNDER
IT HUNDRED FOURTEEN YOUR FOR
COLLEGES COLLEGES.
AND HUNDRED FOUR DIFFERENT
OPINIONS BUT.
SOME VERY VOCAL VOICES SAYING.
TOO FAST TOO MANY UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS.
.
BUT I'M NOT EVEN SLOW DOWN BUT
THAT THE WAY YOU'RE GOING JUST
DOESN'T QUITE WORK.
SO. HOW COULD THE LEAK?
IT IN IT THE CAPACITY.
GO FORWARD WHENWHEN HERE'S
SOME MUCH DISSENT.
FROM YEAR ON FROM YOUR MEMBERS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA RIGHT IT I AM
TO BE CLEAR. OUT AND AS YOU'LL
SEE IN THE REPORT THE CEO
WORKGROUP IS NOT SAYING. I WE
ARE A HUNDRED PERCENT SUPPORTIVE
OF THE GOVERNOR'S FRAMEWORK AND
PROPOSAL AS AN AND I THINK.
UNDERSTANDABLY THERE WAS A VERY
STRONG REACTION TO THAT
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL IN THE
FRAMEWORK AND THEN ONCE THE
SIMULATIONS CAME OUT.
THERE WAS A LOT OF DAMAGE
DISEASE STRIKES SO THE CEO WORK
GROUP THAT FRAMEWORK.
AND TRY TO LOOK AT WHETHER THE
KEYS THE ESSENTIAL ELEMENTS THAT
MIGHT PROVIDE. A OUTCOMES BASED
FORMULA.
AND YOU'LL SEE IT'S PHASED AND
SO WE HAVE GREAT DIVERSITY
AMONGST OUR CEOS JUST AS WE HAVE
GREAT DIVERSITY UP AT THE
COLLEGE AND SO. ON.
THIS IS.
THESE ARE RECOMMENDATIONS.
WITH.
SOME SPECIFICITY ALTHOUGH. IT'S
CLEARLY I AM.
UNDERSTOOD THAT THESE THIS WOULD
PROVIDE HARDING UNLESS ESTATE
FURTHER COMMUNICATION SO.
WE THE WORKGROUP HAS TRIED TO
COMMUNICATE IT EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY BUT UNDERSTANDING THAT IT'S
REALLY BEEN A YOU KNOW ENOUGH IN
A MONTH'S TIME SO THAT'S WHY
THOUGH IN THE RECOMMENDATIONS.
IT'S A PHASED IN PROCESS AND THE
KEY IS.
WHAT WE CALL OR THE WORKGROUP
BECAUSE AN OVERSIGHT COUNCIL?
WHICH WOULD DO AN ANALYSIS IN
CONTINUAL ANALYSIS BECAUSE IF
YOU LOOK AT OTHER STATES
THEY ALL HAVE SOME KIND OF A
GROUP THAT LOOKS AT UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES HOW DO WE CHANGE
THE HYDRAULICS. SO WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A LITTLE BIT OF A LONGER
IMPLEMENTATION IN LAST QUESTION
EIGHT WORK IT IS TO US BUT.
BUT SIMILAR TO WHAT WE HAVE IN
LC FF IN QUAKE IN CAPE TWELVE.
THE MULTI YEAR IMPLEMENTATION
AND THAT.
YOU KNOW SO OFTEN SOME OF THAT
THE DESCENT SO DO YOU THINK THAT
THAT THAT KIND OF FORMULA THAT
YOU OUTLINED HERE AND
ASSUMPTIONS FROM THE STATE.
PARTICIPATION WILL MITIGATE SOME
OF THAT CONCERNS FROM ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
I THINK THE WORK GROUP BELIEVES
THAT AGAIN THERE WAS A CONCERN
ABOUT TIME IN DOING ANALYSIS SO.
THAT SO.
THE.
I I GUESS THE ANSWER IS ABSENT
SIMULATIONS AND EVEN WEEK WE
HAVEN'T SEEN SIMULATIONS ARE OF.
THIS TYPE OF APPROACH ABSENT
SIMULATIONS WE WON'T KNOW I GET
I GUESS WHAT I'M ASKING IS THAT.
WHO IS THAT ARE WE COUNTING ON?
CERTAIN REVENUE GROWTH AND
PROPPING IT OVER LIKE A FIVE SIX
YEAR PERIOD. THAT WILL MAKE IT
PALATABLE AND WITHOUT THAT WHO
STILL HAVE SEVERE PROBLEMS.
WELL I THINK REGARDLESS OF THE
FORMULA YOU HAVE IF WE HAVE SOME
KIND OF A SEVERE PROBLEM BUT.
.
AGAIN THE THERE ARE NO
SIMULATIONS IN HERE SO WE DON'T
KNOW THE EXACT IMPACTS BUT.
YOU NEED SOME KIND OF BASE
INCREASE.
FOR THE INSTITUTIONAL CAPACITY
SO I GUESS THE SHORT ANSWER IS.
YES WE NEED TO INCREASE THE
INSTITUTIONAL CAPACITY OF OF THE
DISTRICTS.
FOR THE NEW FUNDING FORMULA TO
BE IMPLEMENTED SO ME JUST A
REALLY QUICK EXAMPLE WITHOUT
INSTITUTIONAL RESEARCH AND SOME
OF OUR SMALLER COLLEGES DON'T
REALLY HAVE A VERY VERY STRONG
INSTITUTIONAL RESEARCH. YOU CAN
DO THE DATA FORMED ANALYSIS THAT
YOU WOULD NEED TO DO TO LOOKING
ORGANIZATION AND FIGURE OUT HOW
CAN WE.
I.
YEAH CHANGE WHAT WE'RE DOING
SOUTH.
AND I THINK APPS REGARDLESS OF
THE FUNDING FORMULA FOR
INSTITUTIONAL CAPACITY THERE
NEEDS TO BE. AT A BASE
ALLOCATION INCREASE FOR THE
COLLEGES SPREAD THE COSTS AND
AND TO SERVE.
STUDENTS THAT WE SERVE IT'S
NECESSARY.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
STEPHANIE DOT ORG THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE DEEPLY
CONCERNED WITH THE PURPOSE WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL.
AS A RESULT FACT IS ACTUALLY
DEVELOPED AN ALTERNATIVE. A
FUNDING PLAN WHICH WE'VE
DISTRIBUTED TO YOU WHICH SHOWS
SIDE BY SIDE OUR PLAN.
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN.
WE ALSO PROVIDING YOU WITH A
WELL RESEARCHED PIECE BY
NICHOLAS HERMAN OF THE SENTRIES
FOUNDATION. WHICH EXPLAINS HOW
OUR PERFORMANCE BASED FUNDING.
LIKE THE KIND IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL.
ACTUALLY EXASPERATED STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS.
THE FACT PLAN IS RESEARCH BASED
AND DESERVES OUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING. MANY RODRIGUEZ ON
BEHALF THE EDUCATION TRUST WEST
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE FUNDING
FORMULA AS JUST THAT HE STARTED
THE CONVERSATION ON HOW WE CAN
MORE EQUITABLY FUND OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WE HEARD THAT THE CURRENT
FUNDING FORMULA IS NOT WORKING.
PARTICULARLY FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS STUDENTS OF COLOR.
ANY FUNDING FOR THEM FORMULA
MOVING FORWARD SHE REALLY
PRIORITIZE LOW INCOME STUDENTS
STUDENTS OF COLOR UNDER OTHER
UNDER REPRESENTED. AND
UNDERPREPARED GROUPS
PARTICULARLY ON ANY OUTCOMES
PIECE ANY PROGRESS OF
MILESTONES.
AND WE'RE HERE TO REALLY TRY TO
INFLUENCE AS MUCH POSSIBLE THINK
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS YOU
GUYS TO PROCESS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION.
ARMED WITH EVERY UP SCHOOL
REFORM PROPOSAL THAT COULD BE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
AND NOW CONCERNED OF COURSE
BECAUSE TO THE EMPLOYEES HEAVY
DUTY I ASK YOU TO CONSIDER AS
YOU EXPLORE THESE NEW FORMULAS
AND THE IMPACT.
TO THE EMPLOYEES TO CONSIDER.
BUILDING OFF OF ITS EXISTING
EXISTING LAW OPTIONS TO CREATE
SOME TYPE OF BUDGET DISCUSSION
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
WITH KEY STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEES BUT
ALSO TO ALSO. A HAVE BASICALLY A
SIGNED OFF BEFORE BODIES ARE
BEING MOVED BECAUSE THE FARMERS
HAVE CHANGE HOW MUCH IS BEING
FUNDED FROM YEAR TO YEAR. HOW DO
WE PROTECT THOSE EMPLOYEES WHO
ARE BEEN GREAT WORKERS BUT DUE
TO UPS AND DOWNS OF THEIR
ENROLLMENT SAUTE UNINTENDED
IMPACT OF THESE FORMULAS?
WOULD JUST CUT OUT THEIR
POSITION AND NOT TO CONSIDER OF
A WAY TO MOVE THEM AROUND. SO WE
WOULD ASK YOU TO CONSIDER US WE
HAVE OUTLINED IN NOW BUDGET
LETTER. TO HAVE A SIGN UP FOR
THE EXCLUSIVE REPRESENTATIVE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL SO THAT AS THEY
PARTICIPATE IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS AND CD'S CHANGES. THAT
THEY AT LEAST HAVE A CHANCE TO
SAVE THOSE POSITIONS WHERE IT IT
MERITS THEY'RE SAVING THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MARIA ALVAREZ
WITH THE HISPANIC ASSOCIATION OF
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES. WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL.
AS WE RECOGNIZE AND APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR'S ATTEMPT TO. LOOK
AT COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
.
DEMOGRAPHICS AND RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE ARE LOW INCOME STUDENTS
OTHER UNDER UNDERREPRESENTED
STUDENTS AT THESE DISTRICTS ARE
TRYING TO SERVE. AND TRYING TO
ALLOCATE ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO
SUPPORT THE STUDENTS UP FIRST
AND FOREMOST
WITH THAT SAID.
THERE ARE SOME COMPONENTS OF
THIS PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE
CONCERNS WITH.
PROBABLY THE TWO BIGGEST ONES
ARE THE OUTCOME MEASURES. WE
BELIEVE STRONGLY THAT THOSE NEED
TO BE ADJUSTED.
AS.
BEEN SAID BY OTHERS SPEAKERS I'D
TO INCLUDE.
PROGRESS TO A DEGREE MEASURES
AND WAITED METRICS.
THE SECOND WOULD BE TO INCLUDE
OTHER UNDERREPRESENTED
POPULATIONS
I'M IN ADDITION TO THE LOW
INCOME POPULATION.
WHICH WOULD INCLUDE.
FIRST GENERATION FOSTER USE
SARAH THANK YOU.
MAKE YOU TEAR. MEMBERS.
NICHOLAS CHVEZ ON BEHALF OF
LONG BEACH COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT WE SUPPORT THE CONCEPT.
OF THE NEW FIVE FORMULA WHICH
FOCUSES ON IMPROVING SOON
OUTCOMES.
BUT IN ORDER IMPROVE SOON
OUTCOMES DISTRICTS MUST NOT
RECEIVE LESS THAN CURRENT LAW.
AND THE FORMULA MUST BE PHASED
IN OVER TIME THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE FEEDBACK
WILL. TAKE ALL THIS.
INTO CONSIDERATION AS I'M SURE
THAT THAT HARMONY FINANCE.
WELL AS WELL ENDOWED WITH THAT
WE ARE ADJOURNED THANK YOU